today history was made when the Speaker
of the House Kevin McCarthy was removed
after Matt Gates filed a motion to
vacate there were what was it 11
defectors Republicans who I shouldn't
call them defectors who who joined with
Democrats and said Kevin McCarthy no
confidence you are no longer speaker we
have more breaking news Kevin McCarthy
will not seek the speakership again
where we go from here I don't know but I
will make it very simple for you in my
opinion obstruction and stagnation in
Congress is better than the Republican
leadership teaming up with Democrats in
defiance of the slim majority that was
hardfought in 2022 what's the point of
Republicans having won the majority if
they're not going to exercise their
power over the budget and in fact Kevin
McCarthy would work secret back room
deals with Democrats to fund war and
potentially bring us to World War II
this is going to be a big conversation
there's a lot here plus Donald Trump of
course he is still in his uh hearing the
the trial for his fraud lawsuit in New
York City and a judge has gagged him in
fact there are reports that he's being
ordered to remove some of his truth
posts about the judge or face jail time
so we're going to talk about all that
before we do my friends head over to
timcast.net X Miami and come to our
event if you can this Friday tickets
have started selling very very quickly
of course what we expected it's the last
week it's it's the it's the week of the
event on October 6 in Miami at 6 PM we
are going to have Patrick Bet David
James O'Keefe and Matt Gates himself I'm
okay look I think it's fair to say
there's a strong possibility considering
everything go everything that's going on
and the amazing work Matt Gates has done
I would not be surprised I have no
reason to say this other than the public
news our understanding is Matt Gates has
he's he's long been uh planning on being
here he's been scheduled for a while he
will will be here but I think it's fair
to say considering what's going on in DC
I wouldn't be surprised if for some
reason he couldn't show up I he's we've
talked to him everything's good I also
believe that when he sh is going to get
a standing ovation the work he's doing
in DC is inspirational it's it's it's
it's it's groundbreaking and it is some
of the most impactful stuff we've seen
in this country pushing back against
corruption it is an honor that he will
be joining us on Friday in in Miami it's
it's going to be an amazing conversation
considering everything we're going to
talk about right now and I hope to see
you there again go to
timcast.net our typical show will only
be happening on Tim cast.com and mainly
it's because we're going to be Unleashed
in the event someone yell something or
we want to say whatever you want it's
going to be a timcast members exclusive
show for everybody so I hope to uh uh I
hope you guys sign up and support our
work smash the like button subscribe to
this YouTube channel share the show with
your friends joining us tonight to talk
about this and so much more is Lara
Trump hello do you wantan to oh yeah I'm
I'll get right in here there go great to
be with you guys there's there's no lack
of things to talk about today what I
mean what a day what a time to be alive
in America quite frankly history being
made in some good ways and in some bad
ways uh so it's an honor to be here
thanks for having me completely agree
now uh I think everybody recognizes your
name yes Trump do you want to give a
brief introduction to your work and who
am I uh so my father-in-law you may have
heard of Donald J Trump um married to
Eric Trump we have two children Luke and
Carolina three dogs Ben Charlie and
tiger um i' I've been kind of a a a I
don't even know if you would say a
spokesperson an unofficial spokesperson
for a long time from my father-in-law I
tried to uh to talk about you know the
way we're going to save America and I
believe that'll be making sure Donald
Trump is the 47th president of the
United States I have a show it's called
The Right View it's uh three days a week
and uh I recently released a cover of
Tom Petty's I won back down which folks
on the left have loved so thank you to
everybody out there for all the
commentary yes cool thanks right on well
thanks for coming it's going to be
amazing we got Lukowski hanging out hey
guys do you guys know what the best form
of government is no government the least
government possible no government got it
right no you got it for I agree with LA
on this one possible and that's why I'm
wearing well no no no I agree with Ian
here no government at all uh but that's
why I'm wearing a shirt that reads be
the reason someone stops believing in
government you could get the shirt on
the best political shorts.com we're also
doing a Meetup in real life here for
members of Luke unfiltered.com this
October 8th and uh today's a crazy day I
think it's only going to get crazier
from here but I think there definitely
has been a major energy shift and uh
things could go either way from here but
uh it's absolutely berserk and going to
get a lot crazier from here Ian how are
you I'm great uh absolutely awesome
Miami is treating me very well and I
love the weather um Mike cernovich
tweeted that out the energy shifted
something big something something's just
undulating and moving and changing
history yeah I'm glad you talked about
how we can make the country better
that's what I'm obsessively focused on
it I think a lot of it's in the
technology sector like graphine we can
start pulling carbon dioxide out
ofly I don't know anything about that
I'm just talking about the basics like
making sure people can afford their
groceries we'd like gas at a187 again
energy Independence closed border
unemployment way down yeah like making
sure our kids are actually learning the
basics in school instead of woke
ideology and nonsense those those to me
I think are top of mine takes me to
hydrogen fuel I think we we can we'll
get into it on the show let's talk about
the news okay all right everybody here's
the big story ladies and gentlemen from
timcast.net
in US history shout out to Matt Gates he
is doing the Lord's work I will give you
my simple opinion without bearing the
lead in
2022 Republicans won a narrow majority
very a slim majority and Donald Trump
was heavily criticized by establishment
Republicans and conservatives for
tanking them saying it's his fault that
they didn't have the big red wave
because Americans didn't like them I
disagree I think that's not true but
guess what that argument makes no sense
as soon as McCarthy gets in what's H
what happens he starts cutting back room
deals with Biden and with Democrats
what's the purpose of Republicans
winning a slim majority if the Speaker
of the House is going to cut deals with
Democrats instead of his own party in
fact it's people like Matt Gates that
help give the Republican Party its
majority so those arguments that Donald
Trump is the reason there's no majority
meaningless if you're going to agree
that McCarthy should be working deals
with Democrats because then you may as
well just have a Democrat majority and
so this is my this is my argument
against individuals like Thomas Massie I
like Thomas Massie he's a good dude let
me play this clip for you of what Massie
said in defense of of Kevin McCarthy
this is a referendum
on this institution we have tried
regular order speaker McCarthy has tried
regular order if regular order fails
today if you vacate the speaker nobody
is going to try again this institution
will fail I ain't crying about it
certainly not and my understanding is
I've seen reports Lauren Lauren bobert
supported McCarthy as did Marjorie
Taylor green I I I I respect these
individuals I appreciate the work they
do in Congress but I'm with Matt Gates
on this one you got to keep in mind are
these you're not necessarily supporting
the man you're supporting the office and
the function of the office and maybe
what Thomas is saying is that if if and
Kevin McCarthy's voted out that we won't
have a speaker now and we just won't
have one and like Kevin said I'm not
doing it I'm done other people who who
who can you even think of that could do
it or would do it I Trum this guy Thomas
Massie a lot of people like that idea
Troy Nails tweeted that he nominates
Donald Trump to be speaker seconded I'm
just some guy in the internet though I
hope Matt gate seconds it it doesn't
have to be a congress member it could be
I think let's throw you know Donald dunk
there Donald Duck let's throw some
mystical characters let's let's let's
let's let's appoint a dog as the first
Speaker of the House and uh I I think
the dog probably would do a way better
job than all the other speaker of the
houses before them when when when you
when Congress when the leadership in
congress meets with lobbyists and
corporate power in secret to negotiate
deals on what's going to be in the
federal spending bill and then brings
out a 5,000 page omnius and tells every
member of Congress just sign it
otherwise you're blocking the troops
otherwise veterans aren't getting their
benefits that's blackmail that is
extortion you are you are staring down
these good people in Congress people
like Matt Gates who are saying when when
he came on the show last week he said we
want to make sure that we get a bill to
make sure you know disabled veterans
veterans are getting VI benefits are
coming out we don't want them to miss
these payments right so this is what
they do they come to a member of
Congress and threaten the vulnerable and
the people who have served this country
and others and the elderly to force you
into funding locki Maron and other big M
military-industrial complex corporations
how is that an institution we care about
Matt Gates had a simple proposal propose
what you want to fund and we'll vote on
it that makes a lot of sense what's the
problem the problem is they know that if
they present a bill to fund say locked
Martin to to fund War it's going to be
debated and it's going to get
stonewalled it's going to get there's
going to be delays there's going to be
fights because that's the thing American
people actually want to fight about but
they know if they go to you and say your
kids won't get food your kids your the
poor people won't get benefits veterans
won't get paid then what happens a guy
in a wheelchair shows up to your office
and says why am I why why is my pay
getting cut off you're you're
obstructing the government and you try
to tell them we don't want that for you
we're trying to get that that funding
and then Kevin McCarthy actually says
when they're moving to to remove him
when when M Gates files hey if you're
trying to remove a guy who kept the
government open and got the troops paid
we're in a bad place it is blackmail for
the lobbyists and the multinational
corporations Matt Gates did a good thing
here I feel like the American people
probably learned a lot today too because
often times these things these Omnibus
bills they just get P like you said Tim
and people don't really understand all
they know is that the national debt is
going up that we're we're sending money
overseas that things are tougher here
for for the American people so maybe
they learned a little bit today and
maybe people can can actually start to
talk about these things you're right it
shouldn't just be everyone is forced
into this we should have a robust debate
about it we should be talking about what
is actually being spent here and and on
what and um you know I I do I think
overall this is a positive thing I feel
bad a little bit for Kevin McCarthy
though he has had a rough go man it was
tough for him to get elected in there
I'm sure today wasn't a great day for
him I generally think he's a nice guy
but uh but this was probably a necessity
you know we were talking about
leadership the other day and how uh
there's a lot of stories throughout
history of people who don't want to be
the executive like George Washington no
no I don't want to do like well
someone's got to do it and he's like I
don't want okay fine I guess I'll do it
and uh Cincinnatus I think his name was
uh I think that was was it Rome he they
had an emergency said we need someone
take executive author I don't want to do
it and they were like you have to he
took power he AB he resolved the
emergency and then went right back to
farming and we respect that tremendously
Kevin McCarthy should have recognized
this immediately when there was the
fight over the speakership that either
he was going to have to negotiate and
abide by the terms of his negotiations
or he should not do it at all and he
agreed to terms with I what was it 20
some 21 members of Congress who were
saying we want to negotiate these
specific terms otherwise we won't
support you one of those one of one of
those terms my understanding was not to
cut back room deals with Democrats if
Kevin McCarthy wants to go back on his
word and his word is meaningless then I
don't think he's a good guy and he
should have said immediately guys it
will be impossible for me to do this
deal with you I'm not going to be
speaker and this never would have
happened you know as you're talking
about all these people who were like I
don't want to be in this position I I'm
not the right one I actually feel like
if you go back and look at my
father-in-law for years ago I mean we're
talking like the 80s the Oprah
interviews the '90s he said for so long
I don't want to do it but if there ever
came a time where things got so bad I
felt like I had no other choice I would
run for president and amazing to see
that he did it what he did while he was
President the way they fought against
him what is happening now all of it but
as you were saying that that's that's
the only person that came to my mind cuz
he I don't I mean to see what he's given
up and the hell he's gone through man
what what what is his uh his net worth
dropped by oh I'm I don't know how much
but significant especially with the
judge attacking maral laga which is
really weird for a New York judge to be
like it's worthless and uh it's like
okay well I think uh Trump is one of the
rare politicians whose netor has
declined by joining public office where
typically you see Dian Feinstein being
worth what $150 million after being in
Congress and the Pelosi are worth $200
million so you know I I'll give you my
my my my personal view is yeah there's a
big difference between George Washington
and Donald Trump a little bit right just
asach but I've we've seen all the
interviews of of trump being asked since
the 80s and we even had that um who was
it was it it was Trump was on a talk
show with uh I can't remember who it was
it was one of those morning shows and
there I who was it uh they were like you
got to run Donald it wasn't the Oprah
interview there was another one and he
was like well you know I don't know
about that probably morning
Joan was ran yes Rosanne was encouraging
him oh well she's still a fan he's been
encouraged a lot and you would always
say no but but back to the main story I
think we have this tweet uh pulled up I
think it's actually the second did I did
I pull this up Congressman Troy Nails
he's a good dude we've had him on the
show several times says Kevin McCarthy
will not be running again a speaker I
nominate Donald Trump for speaker of the
house please and Matt Gates did this the
first time around second it and you know
I I just I I don't see the excuse for
any member of Congress to to not go for
bold changes DC the concern is if
someone nominates Oprah and then they
win like cuz it's a popularity contest
all the Democrats are like we need
somebody famous to get everyone to say
yes to it I get that but Republicans
aren't going to play that game and if
Republicans have the majority and can
win if they just agree how about the
former Republican president well does it
only take eight Republicans to side with
the Democrats to push someone in or nine
or something five five or six I think
even I think it it's not five or six I
think it was it might be 11 it's what is
it I don't know I guess my followup
question L than that it might be six if
Trump were to take it you know would uh
would he still be able to run for
president as the speaker of the house or
is that a conflict that I don't know
it's a good question I don't see why not
cuz he's not a member of Congress he
would just be speaker i''d be really
interesting and even even if he were a
member of Congress he could still run
for president you know I know it's just
not reality but people were talking
about a few years ago like Steve Bannon
was saying nominate Trump for speaker
vote him in his speaker and then when
you impeach Biden and convict Biden and
Kamala Trump becomes president what are
the what are the qualifications for the
speaker like what are the the main
things you need from that person what do
you mean like Charisma do you need
intelligent do you need like those
probably favorable yeah Connections in
business in the industry um or is that
actually a bad thing like uh so how do
you want these people do you want them
to be like I I would say their
qualifications the requirements not
necessarily qualifications because that
implies like a procedural thing but the
the characteristics we're looking for in
any leader is going to be Integrity
honesty transparency to the best of
their abilities I understand we have
security issues something completely
lacking in Congress
no one you know very few people have in
there but but I think someone that
doesn't roll over on their back and let
the Democrats have their way with them I
I think that's the first thing I think
anyone that's not a rhino anyone that's
not a neoconservative anyone who doesn't
want to perpetuate the larger proxy war
in Ukraine right now I think this is a
larger kind of referendum against
Congress failing the American people
throughout many years now they never
represented the will of what people
actually wanted there was never a public
referendum on if we should start a proxy
war in Ukraine there was never a
referendum on the debt ceiling Kevin
McCarthy another thing he did he made it
that the the Biden Administration could
print and borrow as much money as they
want until
2025 right now just a few days ago the
debt went up
$275 billion in just one day it is set
to increase to almost $1 trillion in
just one month it just hit $33 trillion
America is being destroyed by a lot of
the corporate influences that have
hijacked Congress and this is a
referendum saying we had enough stop it
let let me pull this up we have this
from Gallup right here in uh 2020 is
this 2022 2023 I'm sorry September 1st
2023 the approval rating for Congress is
at
177% look at that right after 911 I know
I was trying to figure out what that was
I know look at that false flags are
Terri 17 177% and my question is to
Thomas Massie legitimate I am not being
a dick I genuinely asking for what
reason do we want to preserve the
current iteration of an institution that
has 82% disapproval not only does defy
any Democratic standard but even if we
want to operate on a super majority
principle or just say it should be
representative and not direct democracy
I think it's fair to say when 82% of
people are like we don't like what
you're doing it's time to change this
system it's it's a simple choice you
know deadlock or allow the government to
steal your money and then Finance it and
give it to Ukrainian oligarchs that of
course will be using it for their own
purposes what do you want I prefer the
deadlock so it's not it's not even about
Ukraine I mean I know that's a big
talking point right now but let's just
talk about the problems this country has
faced that the left has been screaming
about that we've been talking about how
many years did we get the Flint Water
Crisis as big news with Democrats saying
we got to fix these pipes you know what
I say my answer is deal we stop funding
war in foreign countries be it
Afghanistan Syria whatever and I'll I
say we divert that money to the pipes in
Newark in Pittsburgh in Flint and you
know what then because it doesn't cost
that much money to fix the pipes we
launch a commission to start going and
hiring contractors to fix pipes
everywhere better yet we can build
Bridges fix our roads we can hire
American construction workers hey maybe
we can build a Ballard fence down on the
southern border with the money that
we're spending graine I like how you're
thinking out of graphine you know what
Ian deal I tell you this we have a deal
we stop funding the war in Ukraine
Afghanistan Syria all of these foreign
excursions that have done nothing for
the American people and Congress approve
secure fencing and homes we'll start
we'll start doing homes and we'll build
it out of graphine if that's what you
want you can 3D print tubes and then
lock them into joints and make like doed
housing really cheap with that stuff
they actually there's yeah uh what was
it geodesic Dums we talked about they
they actually they inflate a big bag and
then they they wire they put wire around
it and cement it and then deflate the
bag and it creates like a dome that's
smart look at that part of the reason
why I'm going a little hand heavy on it
right now is because at a um Rice
University they figured out how to
create hydrogen fuel um and every
kilogram of fuel they're making out of
like waste they'll hit it with lasers
and make it it produces a byproduct of
graphine of $44.50 worth of graphine for
every kilogram we trying to find a use
for that so we actually make before this
you had to spend money to get hydrogen
now you're making money because you're
getting a product in the in the and then
you can make Electronics out of it or
you can burn it and I and I will I will
grab that particularly esoteric concept
C and bring it back to this if Congress
came out with a bill that said we will
take new fuel by products to produce
products here in this country and create
American jobs they approval would be
higher if Kevin McCarthy came out
banging and screaming about the need to
fund graphine their approval rating
would be higher Ian there's a bunch of
comments right now with people talking
about you laying down pipes I'm not
going to get into that one but but but
you you know you guys are talking about
some very interesting Concepts about
what you guys want Congress to do I
don't want them to do anything stop
taking my money stop trying to fix
problems leave people alone let the free
market fix whatever problems are
occurred that usually are occurred by
the government so I I think if the
government steps away from our life
stops intervening stops taxing stops
regulating stops saying you could do
this but you can't do this stops
favoring the multinational corporations
and the banking Elite then I think life
would be better for everyone and I think
if they just took a step back allowed
the free market to be a free market
everything would be way better than it
is right now aged and starting point is
not that we just overnight say we no
longer have any spending at all I think
realistically there's so much we don't
see in terms of federal spending that we
would like and would need at least to
get to a point where we can get away
from this kind of thing but the the
obvious and immediate is veteran
benefits oh gosh I I I don't think any
anyone in their right mind is going to
be like let's just cut the government
off like when we were we were talking
about ha the government's shutting down
met Gates is like no It it means
veterans aren't going to get paid like
that's not a good thing and we're like
right right we're we're kind of just
goofing off fair point but he did say
one of the first things we get through
if we're not going to fund the
government is making sure that our
veterans get paid I I do not like the
idea that whether you like the wars or
the foreign policy or not I don't like
the idea that anybody who who served in
my name would be left high and dry
without benefits I would gladly pay if
that was the case so when we talk about
we don't want the government spending
our money I completely agree with Luke
as it pertains to their corporate
buddies revolving door policies and then
as it pertains to the good men and women
in uniform who served us in our nation
whether or not our leaders have have led
them astray I think these people deserve
more money you a lot more money part of
why there's been so much push back
against what Matt's doing and uh to
destroy the Omnibus spending package
concept is that it's literally and I'm
using the word correctly here completely
and totally impossible for the 430
people in Congress or however many to
read all those bills they don't have
enough time oh God no so we're going to
have to complete change the way that our
Republic functions and let the people
read the bills decentralizes no no no
they should not be spending that much
money so there were priorities when like
Matt Gates said you know they come to me
and said we've got to fund the military
we've got to fund veterans like easy get
the bill it's approved like we we all
agree it's done there's no question
there's no obstruction every member of
Congress says yes to that but then they
want to fund the Department of Education
now there's a debate the the issue is
435 or how many is it 430 was it 435 I
don't know that uh uh members of
Congress if they can't read that many
bills should not be uh voting on them
and spending the money or we should have
more members of Congress cuz I
think we used to have one for every
70,000 people now we have one for every
like 900,000 hum and they can't
functionally well they function I want
people to represent themselves honestly
and I'm kind of tired of Representative
thing I understand there a stop Gap if
you don't want the mob to go crazy but
people have the ability to to govern
themselves and I think we should use
modern technology to do it I disagree I
agree technology and Technology but I
don't think you want people who look my
view is this we certainly want
decentralized power I like the idea of
Representatives I don't like the idea of
how they've been basically exploiting
and lying to us but the issue is if you
are a Tradesman if you're a teacher or a
nurse you don't follow politics all day
every day and that means someone whose
job it is to provide a service outside
of politics needs to be able to trust
you to go to you and say hey man I trust
you to do what's right you're a good
person I give you my vote and that
person takes up their whole time and
energy focusing on policy issues and
making the country work I'm fine with
that the problem is for too long corrupt
individuals have been like these suckers
actually believed me and they're ripping
everybody off and they're lying about it
it's too easy to bribe because there's
so few of them but but Ian the Pakistani
gender studies are not going to fund
themselves okay who's going to fund the
Sri Lankan speedboats who's going to
fund all these other program that of
course are absolutely pointless and
steal your money for no reason at all
what who's going to do it I like I like
the America first idea like you're
proposing honestly like there is so much
that this country needs there's so much
we could do so much good here that could
be done I mean shouldn't we at least
Focus here first before we send all this
money overseas and I think that that's a
real frustration I think that that is
the good thing that came out of this um
and I do agree the 82% who are very
unhappy with Congress would probably be
a lot happier if they actually saw the
impact of all of this exorbitant
spending but no one ever sees it you go
into like LaGuardia Airport I remember I
used to fly into LaGuardia if it was
raining there would be like trash cans
there to catch the rainwater and I was
like God this is what some people see
when they first arrive in the United
States of America this is the first
impression we are supposed to be the
leader of the Free World and the
superpower and yet this is how our
country is functioning right now do
something different yeah I think Donald
Trump actually exemplifies the problem
of government in a unique way outside of
just the uh outside of the fact that
they just strapped weights to him
falsely accused him of tons of things
they're trying to persecute him
prosecute him I think you look at
someone who built this this Empire knows
how to run multiple companies creates
multiple Brands the left tries to argue
but look at all those bankruptcies it's
the stupidest argument ever 500 plus
companies in a handful of bankruptcies
and bankruptcies don't mean failure it
means you're literally preserving the
business but you take someone like that
he becomes president still gets things
done despite what's going on and the and
the challenges he still faced show when
you when you go to the government and
say hey we need to put up say like
suicide Nets on the Golden Gate Bridge
half a billion dollars later it gets
done you go to the private sector and
they compete over it and $10 million
later it gets done I guess what what was
the old saying uh when in 2016 uh uh
under budget and had a
schedule that's how he operated as a
businessman and I actually think that
when he became president he believed he
could get so much accomplished and he
thought well gosh if I just run things
like I did a business then it will say I
mean you he talk about locked Martin he
renegotiated for the new Air Force Ones
which by the way will start flying in
2025 just in time for him to arrive on
them as first on president but he
actually tried to save money he tried to
do all these things he went to South
Korea and he said why is it that that
you know we're funding all of this stuff
over here for you guys you can fund it
yourself we're going to stop sending a
bunch of money over here to you you
could fund your some of your own stuff
he saved the the country I mean unknown
amounts of money that no one ever talks
about and it made zero difference no one
talked about it no one cared about it
and I think it's insane that you can
have someone with the the ability like
he had and yet this government is in
such a mess that it really made almost
no difference well to be fair he did
also spend a lot of money and he did
also increase the the deficit and the
debt a lot I do think he had a lot of
policies that were very favorable
towards blueco collar workers I think
more favorable than any other president
uh in in our time but the deficit was
increased a lot under his presidency and
I think I think we're still dealing with
those ramifications today because of
that I kind of see the difference of
running the country and a business as
like um the solution to our economy
isn't in money it's not in finance it's
in the productive capability of people
so you could print shitloads of money
and build graphine factories and start
producing of hydrogen fuel and make us
the wealthiest country on Earth but just
printing the money like it doesn't take
money to do that I mean we can print as
much money as we want right now so we
just need to incentivize people to do it
we need our factories back we need
manufacturing back we need to produce
things here in this country we do you
know how hard it is to get anything
really made in America for any like
decent amount of money everything is so
expensive to do here we have to change
that otherwise we're we're going to be
in a really bad spot look at Co look at
the supply chain how much we learned how
much you know we realize we really
weren't doing here yeah you need to make
it here you need to incentivize business
here in this country the hard chemicals
like uh East Palestine when that train
derailment went off and it annihilated
the community like that's why we moved a
lot of that stuff over to China CU like
if it spills we don't want it to spill
next door so I but I do believe the risk
of having the Chinese producing this
stuff is outweighs the risk of
contamination but I mean contamination
is devastating too I just yeah it's like
a two-sided coin that obviously you know
what it is it's these climate change
policies and so what Democrats do is
they say okay you can't make a business
that has x amount of carbon or whatever
so the companies say Okay China it is so
when when Joe Biden comes in this is why
I think they're lying I think they are
full of it Joe Biden says we're going to
bring back these restrictions climate
change is bad now you can't produce x
amount of carbon you have this these
taxes you have these fees but hey we're
going to remove tariffs so you can
import products for free he is outright
telling businesses send your F Factory
to China ABS yep that's exactly right
and I mean it it's so devastating in so
many different ways I think to our
country I mean if you look at inflation
if you look at the the job situation in
this country this is this is a I don't
want to say it's an easy fix but it
seems so obvious and it was all set up
so well I give my father-in-law a lot of
credit the tariffs on China the trade
deals that he negotiated with China I
mean who would have ever thought we'd
have something like that honestly yeah
he was he was the guy that actually
opened my eyes to the danger of our
relationship with the CCP I didn't I
knew it was like te ten I I knew it was
not good terrifying I just didn't until
he was like China China and I was like
okay I still don't get it but then
eventually I started to realize they
produce the antibiotics you know if they
cut off our if they poison our
antibiotics like with fentanyl one day
they just decide 90% of China is waiting
right now and salivating over what they
see happening in this country the fact
that Joe Biden is our president that we
seem in a weakened state that our
economy doesn't seem like it's it's
headed in the right direction for the
long term they are ready to pounce and
take over as the superpower of the world
and Donald Trump was the first to call
them on it he's been talking about China
for decades and if you go back to his
2015 speech when he announced he was
running for president he talked about
China then and people were like he's so
crazy so unhinged about China he was
right about them it is it's actually
terrifying if you really think about
what their their longterm game plan is
in China they're ready to take over do
you think he knew because he' been doing
business there for so long and just knew
how they they function yes absolutely
big part of it for sure Tim you look
like you're pulling up another story
well yeah Kevin McCarthy is speaking I
can't find the video right now it's live
so I
imagine before it pops up on on Twitter
so we'll we'll pull that up in a second
but for for the uh for the time being
let's jump to this story from our good
friends over at CNN judge issues gag
order and rebukes Trump after social
media post attacking his Clerk and uh we
also have this one from Dr Kelly Ward
judges threatening real Donald Trump
with jail if he doesn't remove this post
from truth social well of course we will
highlight that post so you can all know
the news Trump truthed Schumer's
girlfriend Allison R Greenfield is
running his case against me this case
against me how disgraceful disgraceful
this case should be dismissed
immediately linking to a uh tweet from
judicial protest saying why is Judge
enron's principal law clerk Allison R
Greenfield ping around with Chuck
Schumer well I guess because of this the
judge says Trump is here by gag which I
find funny considering the Jud judges
allowing cameras in the courtroom this
whole thing is very obviously an attempt
to drain Trump's energy and resources to
attack his Circle and cause political
damage to interfere in the 2024 election
absolutely I mean that's what they've
all been about this is another example
this one is particularly egregious if
you look at the fact that you have
Leticia James the Attorney General of
the state of New York who ran a campaign
not on doing what was best for the
people of the state of New York not
locking up criminals not really going
after the hard crime my gosh New York
City is a mess you just take that City
in and of itself let alone the rest of
the state she's supposed to be looking
out for she ran a campaign where she
said I'm going to be a real pain in his
ass I'm going to go in to the attorne
Atty General's office every day suing
him and then going home she never cared
a second about anything other than
Donald Trump so here you have a
situation where there is no plaintiff
there is no person that was injured
there is no issue whatsoever on behalf
of these Banks who made tens if not
hundreds of millions of dollars off of
these loans that they gave the Trump
organization and yet here we are with my
father-in-law now for the second day and
I assume tomorrow as well in court in
downtown Manhattan over this absolute
nonsense and these people want to
dissolve his business make no mistake
about it they want to inflict maximum
pain yes they want to inflict maximum
pain they ordered it this judge ordered
it in a summary judgment before even
hearing all the facts of everything when
he told everyone Mara Lago is worth $18
million what an utter joke and then
whenever people said what does that mean
what what do you want dissolved he said
I'm not ready to rule on that yet it is
wild stuff it is Banana Republic at at
best I got to I got to read this uh this
quote here this is too good the judge
said this morning one of the defendants
one of the defendants posted on a social
media account a disparaging untrue and
personally identifying post about a
member of my staff although I have since
ordered the post deleted and apparently
it was it was also emailed out to
millions of other recipients the judge
said in court personal attacks of any
member of my court staff are
unacceptable inappropriate and I will
not tolerate them I just love that the
that that Trump emailed it out to
everybody just to make sure you got it
hey look you can order someone to delete
a post on social media but once the
email is sent it's sent yeah that's
that's that's the benefit of doing of of
using email I just think it's absolutely
absurd that the judge is telling Donald
Trump he can't
speak this is unrelated to the trial
when when it comes to civil suits it is
unsurprising that there will be uh gag
orders right if you if if if person a
sues person B it's it it is normal for
the judge to be like guys don't
disparage each other Donald Trump is
talking about the court mhm I mean so
you know maybe someone might advise him
not to do it I just think the Judge
putting cameras in the courtroom issuing
a issuing a summary judgment has already
shattered the judicial Norms we we
expect and this makes no sense what was
the personal attack he said she was
piling around with Schumer it's a
picture of her with by the way that's
very relevant whenever this is an
individual who's part of his staff there
and this is supposed to be an impartial
judge are you kidding me this is like
the Attorney General is supposed to be
impartial as well these people have an
agenda they have had a bias obvious bias
against Donald Trump from day one so I
think it's very relevant I think it was
appropriate to call that out that that
attorney general isn't impartial she's
very partial she's very biased she
clearly has a political agenda there's
so many horrible crimes there's so many
things happening in New York City right
now and for the city to spend their
resources going after the former
president of the United States for this
is just absolutely ridiculous in my
opinion and a waste of time a waste of
taxpayer money but but also more
importantly just also at the same time
is making Trump more popular than ever
didn't didn't this was Leticia James
right yes yeah didn't she run on going
after Trump absolutely well just
recently there was a a left-wing
activist in New York City who was with
his girlfriend when a deranged man came
up and stabbed him twice killing him no
he he came up to the deranged man let's
be clear the the the news will have you
think that the derang man approached him
he approached the derang man yelling at
him right saying hey hey get trying to
get his attention the der man turned on
him and was like der guy walks past him
knocks over scooters this guy gets up
and yells something says something to
him the guy gets in his face the dude
stands his ground then the deranged man
stabs him killing him and uh he's still
on the loose and he's still on and I can
only say one thing look these are the
activists that voted in advocated for a
DA who is going to go after the former
president instead of dealing with the
crime in their own City I think a lot of
the the the thing that scares me a lot
of the part that scares me about this is
that some of them yes they're
emotionally going after Donald himself
but some of them I think the the deep
deep dark thing they're going after
anyone that would do what he was trying
to do by rationalizing our industry like
the people they want I think there's a
global bank I don't know man but all
signs leave the world economic forum and
the New World Order
and it is a the world order is changing
and that they want to create this build
back better this this we weird digital
technocracy you mean no borders you mean
free flow of people all around do you
mean a centralized yeah banking system
you mean you could just like have it in
your head you just think it's it's it's
actually terrifying you could go down a
real dark hole you could have 10 fo hat
but the only thing uh we know about a
conspiracy theor is it's like 6 months
until it actually becomes true generally
speaking Yeah I'm comfortable speaking
dis fervently about it now because of
the last two or three years R thing was
a
week yeah they're like it's a
coordinated against Russell bran the
media is like what a cooky conspiracy
theory and then we get leaked letters
from UK govern the UK government being
like we want him removed we're we're
concerned he can make money on your
platform and then he starts getting
banned it's like oh okay the government
was doing as they're coordinating the
hit pieces and of course releasing key
information um tidbit by tidbit by
tidbit to of course build it up and have
the maximum effect in order to try to
hurt him I I think something very
similar is happening with a lot of these
District Attorneys a lot of them are
usually financed by George and Alex
Soros have financed them who have bought
them off and have created policies
inside of the United States where you
could hurt people you won't go to jail
you won't be in trouble you defend
yourself against individuals trying to
hurt you or steal your property you go
to jail you express political thoughts
and idea you go to jail but you're
you're a criminal you you could get Lo
get loose get free anytime you want
because of these policies that were
implemented without any kind of vote
without any kind of referendum and all
it took was secret billionaire money
that Finance these individuals that were
a part of the larger ideology that these
people are implementing and this
ideology is one that is of course Very
uh leftist very similar to what happened
in communism very similar to of course
what happens in a lot of totalitarian
regimes where people are punished just
for their political Expressions this is
this is the current world that we're
living in which is absolutely terrifying
and should scare the crap out of
everyone because there's no longer a
justice system there's a A system that
uses power to punish people people
politically Elon Musk on Twitter or on X
rather Elon uh are we ever going to call
it X I'm about to really I like calling
at Twitter still I do it kind of
everyone's like X also known as Twitter
sorry to you ever going to call it that
cuz a lot of people don't know what
you're talking about exactly on X it
sounds like ecstasy like I'm tripping
I'm on X everybody's on X right D from
pop culture is calling it Twix that's a
good one well he said that's even more
confusing to yeah he he actually said
the word that um uh George Soros was
figured out how to do politics through
Arbitrage which is basically send a
little bit to a lot of places and just
kind of buy the system by getting all
these local Das and and yeah that's what
he does that's crazy that's nuts what
does he do it through multiple
businesses or something I I I don't know
all the ins and outs of the Soros uh
Dynasty and their their multi multiple
organizations and and multiple Nos and
multiple ways that they're just
funneling a lot of their money and
financing a lot of these woke leftist
radicals that are in positions of power
and clearly abusing those positions
but I I I I keep saying I think we are
winning and by we I'm referring to the
anti-establishment faction which
includes post liberals Libertarians I
always have to clarify this uh you look
at today and you know one of the Brian C
I think it was just tweeted this is a
win for Democrats not Republicans it was
eight Republicans who sided with with
Democrats to ask Kevin McCarthy the
Republicans voted to keep them in and
I'm just like yo it it was a win for the
anti-establishment I I it it's obvious
we knew it was going to be Democrats
voting to remove him but and Democrats
are looking at it like I think it's
really funny cuz democrats should have
actually wanted want him to stand in he
was cutting deals with them but they
can't they're politically trapped you
look at the cultural victories you look
at Matt Gates's massive historic Victory
today anti-establishment is winning I
hope so there there's a quote from Gates
he said something the effect of uh I'm
paraphrasing said based on his recent
conversations with the former recent
based on his recent conversations with
the former president he feels like he's
is doing the right thing something that
affect not to say that Trump actually
told him to do it but that Matt Gates
feels confident this is the move that
has to be made I I I believe it is I
believe it's about time someone stood up
to the corrupt mechanisms of Congress
the challenge we face is that for
congress it is always easier to Kick the
Can down the road instead of ripping the
bandaid off and uh Ron Paul had that
famous quote I'm again paraphrasing
where he said you know we got to get out
of Iraq and Afghanistan they keep saying
oh well it was a mistake going in but we
need an exit strategy so we can't just
leave and he says if if if you prescrib
the wrong medication you don't just keep
them on the same medication you get them
off and it's like yes we've been sitting
by with Congress broken forever being
like well you know it's going to be bad
if we change it's going to be bad if we
keep doing it we can't we got to change
it some of some medicines you want to
wean off of I I know I know basically
surrender in Afghanistan was like just
stopping tury no I disagree that was
that was that that
yeah abandoning bam Air Force Base is
not ripping the band off it's pouring
it's pouring sewage onto your open wound
that's insane but my point is with
what's going on with Trump with what
they're doing I want everyone to to to
realize these moves are only being made
out of Terror and Desperation they're
trying to dissolve the Trump
Organization for what purpose it strips
them of resources it ties up his his his
his time and energy he should be
campaigning right now they're they're
trying to set this trial which one the
federal trial for just before super
Tuesday they did the day before Tuesday
that all of these things are so
obviously just how can we cement Trump's
legs down to stop him from winning it is
quite literally them cheating to win in
2024 and by cheating what I mean is we
expect elections to be a little dirty
but for the most part it's how many
votes can you get what they're doing now
is can we use the legal system to damage
Trump's life and threaten his lawyers so
that no one works with him again you've
got in Georgia his lawyers being
indicted Jenna Ellis for just literally
providing him legal advice and then you
also have I think it was out of uh out
of Colorado two lawyers finded
$187,000 by a judge for simply arguing
Trump's position they sued an appealed
to the Supreme Court saying we're
lawyers we were asked to represent this
individual that's what we do it's a
constitutional right and the Supreme
Court said shove it so they have to pay
nearly 200 grand for for doing one thing
Trump said says here's my argument they
say We'll craft the argument for you and
now the the the judge in the case says
200 Grand what they're trying to do is
make sure no lawyer ever worked with
Trump again yeah well they want they
want to inflict maximum pain they want
as much collateral damage as humanly
possible because they don't want anyone
around Donald Trump they don't want him
to have a circle of people he can trust
he can rely on who can go out there I
mean if you look at this case right now
he's been in court over the past two
days this Leticia James AG case every
person had testified that my husband
Eric and my brother-in-law da had
nothing to do with any of these
valuations and yet they got dragged into
it too why would you do that maximum
pain I mean to me it's so much of what
that January 6 committee sham nonsense
was which was it wasn't really about
anything other than warning people if
you dare step out of line again you
could be on the hot seat next don't ever
question anything this government
government does or tells you to do again
because next time it could be you it
might be Donald Trump today next time it
could be you and it it will be I'll give
you an example of how of the game
they're playing when it comes to the the
the judge in the in this Trump lawsuit
AOC made a video after January 6 where
she said someone banged on her door she
went hid in the bathroom Heard a Voice
say where is she where is she and she
thought she was going to die and all
that stuff what she was doing was making
you believe that she thought riers broke
into her office immediately conservative
said her office isn't even in the
capital building to which the media
responded there are tunnels connecting
it and then this one surprised the heck
out of me her I I I I I I did the whole
timeline I fact checked everything and I
said her story took place one hour
before the capital was even breached she
was she was manipulating the context of
the day most people did not know the
timeline the only thing they knew is
that on January 6 people stormed the
capital so when she says on January 6
someone banged on my door and I was
scared she is lying to you
because she knows you don't understand
the basic context around this day what
this judge is doing is very very similar
he says the tax assessor says the
property is only worth around 18 to 20
million at Mar Lago Trump is inflating
the value of his properties he's
committing fraud what do regular people
here who don't pay attention judge rules
Trump committed fraud fraud but here's
the funny thing anybody paying attention
immediately recognizes the problem here
depending on how deep you go in terms of
paying attention if you're someone like
me I just pull up the actual property
the comparables in in Palm Beach and
West Palm Beach and I'm like Mar Lago 17
12 acres from from Beach to Beach and a
third acre goes for you know 10 $30
million with a house on it a a lot
that's just half acre is like 1020
million how is maral Lago as as just
land worth less than this however
anybody with a cursory understanding of
real estate knows the values aren't set
by the individual it's appraised by the
lender exactly when when you mentioned
Eric and Don have nothing to do with the
evaluation right the bank comes in and
says here's what we think yeah they have
their own due diligence they they have a
fiduciary responsibility to send someone
in they're not going to take my word for
it if I'm like yeah I got a house down
the street it's worth 10 billion dollars
you can trust me on that of course they
have to look out for themselves it's a
business at the end of the day that's
the crazy part of all of this and you're
right the the the truth is that the
average person out there probably
doesn't understand this kind of minutia
right all they cared about and all they
have ever cared about is that headline
Donald Trump and the word fraud next to
it and that's it that's the end game for
them they want to inflict maximum damage
to him they want to tie him up but Luke
you said it I do believe it's making him
stronger I feel like all of this stuff
has shaken people awake that mug shot
forget it that mug shot was probably the
biggest mistake they ever made the
number of people who have approached me
post mug shot and been like you know
what I really have never paid attention
to politics I wasn't sure I like Donald
Trump but that mug shot somehow to some
people represented A system that had
been failing them that was broken that
was working against them working against
Donald Trump and they were like wait a
minute I see what they're doing to this
guy and now their their eyes are open
and they're not going to be closed again
and and it actually unified a nation the
Democrats really liked it and the
Republicans really liked it I made a
t-shirt of it right away um and and a
lot of people were buying it on the left
and on the right it it it didn't matter
but but more importantly every time they
do go after Trump you see his poll
numbers go up and and right now he's
he's higher than he was this entire
election cycle even though he's saying
some kind of very interesting things but
uh just for yourself I'm kind of curious
as a trump do you feel like you're under
a spotlight do you feel like you're
targeted do you feel like someone is
just waiting to see if you're going to
do anything wrong just so they could
blow it up in the media every single
second of every single day absolutely
yeah I mean these people are disgusting
and to be honest with you if it if it
weren't my family and I hadn't had
firsthand experience with this sort of
stuff I would say this is I mean that's
really overblown there's no way but it
it's true they they pick apart anything
that any of us do they try to attack us
for it and and honestly you really think
that if any of us had I don't know
obtained a firearm illegally and lied on
a federal gun application and then
throwing the gun in a garbage can next
to a school we wouldn't be locked up
right now get the heck out of here
that's the that's the frustrating thing
is the clear double standard that exists
between someone with the last name Trump
and someone with the last or just you
know smoked crack and uh you know bought
ladies of the night and you know took
photos of themselves doing it uh I mean
I mean there's controversy on on both
you know sides there but it's just
absolutely crazy how far the media will
go and how um they will just in many
instances make stuff up in order to try
to frame you guys as really horri you
want great what I I was going to ask you
what's one of the craziest ways that the
media has attacked you that had no
reality um at all so last year we had a
hurricane come through the state the
hurricane hit the western side of the
State of Florida I live on the east
coast of Florida so anyone with a little
knowledge of hurricane knows there are
bands of rain that come through and in
between those bands it's clear it's fine
my kids were cooped up inside they
canceled school that day so I took my
kids and my dogs just down the
neighborhood on a little walk in between
the bands of rain my son was on one of
these little like motorized tractor
things that he had and I took a video
because all of a sudden we got poured on
out of nowhere with the rain I posted it
on social media people were calling for
child protective services I'm not even
joking to come to my house there were
multiple stories written about how I was
an unfit mother I mean it is it's so
insane I yeah that that's one of the
probably
least faves of of my past couple years
this getting crazy huh dude yeah yes but
I I was as you guys were talking firstly
you got caught in the rain with your kid
that's that's I guess normal I said I
CAU I cap I captioned it character
building experience cuz it is sometimes
it rains sometimes it rains people like
she's putting her child in danger in a
hurricane oh my God okay this uh build
back better which is like a world
economic Forum thing then Biden starts
saying it okay is it not that's not a
coincidence humans well he got made fun
of by who was it Boris Johnson for for
stealing build back better I just
constantly so so the Brits were doing it
too it's if this this like organized
four different indictments unrelated all
in like within the course of like six
months on Donald Trump it's not that's
not a coincidence all the day after a
hunter Biden or Joe Biden big
information drop happened some yeah but
understand it's a standalone complex and
a conspiracy so there's the bigger
picture which is all these indictments
happening I don't think you need New
York to coordinate with Georgia and the
federal government these are people who
have Trump derangement syndrome who are
going to do these things of their own
valtion in fact as soon as the feds make
a move then George is like now's our
chance now we can pile on some of this
stuff like right every time Hunter
Biden's indicted there's like a UFO leak
or some new indictment of trump comes
out that seems coordinated and a group
of people organizing that at a high
level but all of the attacks on Trump
it's because these people are deranged
and they're going to keep doing it
that's look you look at what happened to
Brett Kavanaugh with uh uh that woman
sweatnik I think her name was accusing
him of being at parties where they would
line up outside of rooms to take
turns just you know having their way
with women against their will I'll keep
it as family friendly as I can she
didn't no one came to her and told her
to say it right or my assumption is that
maybe I'm wrong it's just that these
people are so deranged they're like I'll
just do it and they come out of their
own Val and it looks coordinated when it
often isn't man I spent my youth
believing in people that they would be
honest I just thought like if you're
good and honest then more people will be
good and honest and we can make a good
and honest society and then I'm learning
in my midlife that deceitfulness and and
evil is like the way to lead like it
throughout history that's how they've
been doing it they kill their opponents
they take control and they say that they
were the good guys yeah there's that
tweet I referenced about the it was a
video of hyena eating some kind of ulet
alive they were they were eating it from
the belly EV ating it and the Tweet said
it is not the case that the most vicious
and evil people are punished in fact
nature shows us that they are often
rewarded and that was the point that you
watch this poor I think like a Wilder
Beach or something struggling to get up
being devoured alive and yeah there's an
old uh there's an old hacker joke saying
if you're not cheating you're not trying
I understand Jesus in a way from the
Bible like what they said that he he was
just like they don't know what they're
doing man and he just let it happen cuz
like what can you do it gets to a point
where like I'm not going to become evil
at least I don't want to so like how do
I how do I really help Society without
becoming evil yeah how much crazier do
you think it's going to get cuz I think
we're we're you know in the middle of
the election cycle but I I think it's
going to get crazier age what do you
think is going to happen cuz we have the
indictments we have the court hearings
but they're not stopping Trump they're
making him more popular I really do
believe we're we're in an inroad where
the system is becoming more and more
desperate how desperate do you think
they will become well I think they they
become more desperate by the day because
I think you know you look at who they're
running on the Democrat side Joe Biden
and apparently KLA Harris two of the uh
lowest polling favorability uh I mean
president vice president in history
these two are just absolutely horrible
one worse than the other they have a big
problem on their hands they have no
bench on the Democrat side we seem to
have a little bit of a bench on the
other other side of the aisle but I
think they're getting more desperate by
the day because it must be so
frustrating to see all the effort
they're putting out against one guy and
it's boomeranging back and it is having
the opposite of the intended result for
them so I I'm sure it's going to get a
lot worse let me let me jump to this
story we have this from The Daily Mail
shock poll shows RFK Junior's run as an
independent could pull more support from
Trump than Biden in 2024 and the poll
basically shows it asks if you have a
favorable view of RFK Jr and they find
that Republicans actually have a more
favorable view than Independence and
Democrats Democrats have a very
relatively unfavorable view of RFK Jr of
course we're hearing now that he may run
as an independent but I actually want to
say right away I think this is wrong
Republicans have favorable views of Viv
gramas Swami they're voting Trump they
have a favorable view of RFK Jr they are
voting Trump as Phil leonti said last
week Trump's bottom is Rock Solid and I
think that's it could probably be
phrased a lot better but his voter floor
is not going to move 44% of whatever IND
idual who support Trump ain't going to
back anybody else and I like RFK Jr I
have a favorable view of him I'm not
voting for him right I I agree with that
yeah I think this the daily mail's view
is wrong I think the poll is interesting
for sure but I think they're wrong if
you look at Independence 36 to 37 it's
it's within the margin of error the
question is how many independent voters
who would normally vote Democrat will
end up voting RFK Jr instead and will
that Spike Joe Biden I give very oh real
quick Rich bars came on the show and
said if RFK Jr runs it could be a Ross
pero like moment and Trump could end up
winning States like Maine because he
because it'll split enough of the
Democrats and it could he Trump could
end up winning uh uh the presidency with
like 43 44% of the popular vote yeah
that's what happened with Abraham with
Lincoln we talked about that it was a
four-way split four parties I like where
this is going um I don't trust polls
firstly because they can be used to
manipulate public perception I don't and
I I hate to be gu constantly asks but
how many people were pulled here this
like a thousand people and then they
extrapolate thousand and then they tell
you that it it stands for 300 million
and it's like no it's stand for a
thousand well they also didn't ask would
you vote for him they asked Tim what you
said the favorable versus unfavorable I
have a generally favorable view of RFK
Jr I like that he posts workout videos I
sometimes post a workout video I'm okay
with that I think a lot of Republicans
like him because he called out the
Democrats for a lot of their crazy
nonsense that everybody can see is
insane and he was like yeah I don't
agree with that or hey I don't know
maybe you shouldn't be forced to have a
vaccine that's why I think a lot of
Republicans have a favorable view but
you're right the Trump base I don't
believe going anywhere but you I mean
and you had people saying Trump RFK Jr
2024 I've heard that yeah and it's like
okay well probably not but people like
the anti-establishment and I think that
shows you even though RFK Jr has had
anti-2a sentiments in the past the one
of the biggest issues in the election in
2016 20 now even the midterms is
anti-establishment versus establishment
if you're RFK Jr and you say the machine
is broken and I have these political
views people will be like I care less
about your policy positions and more
about your your your opposition to the
corruption in in Congress and DC and the
federal government there was there was
an article released um a couple days ago
highlighting uh how Hillary Clinton was
warning Joe Biden in a private meeting
that a third party candidate would quote
prove disastrous for him as a White
House Insider caus the situation pretty
effing concerning this is the reporting
from The Daily Mail that just happened a
couple days ago so I I I think you know
it is interesting to to see RFK Jr to
see where he's going to be going
allegedly he's going to be announcing on
uh October 9th in Pennsylvania an
independent run that's the rumors that
are circulating right now I don't know
if that's true or not but there is a
very big Stark difference between RFK Jr
and Donald Trump especially when it
comes to coid their response to co their
response to uh operation warp speed and
we have to understand here Donald Trump
was advised by RFK Jr and was going to
launch an investigation into uh these
medical procedures that people get
injected with and uh then uh Donald
Trump decided to take the advice of Bill
Gates and not listen to RFK Jr and not
do that investigation now a a a trump
RFK Jr ticket I think would would would
uh ease a lot of the concerns of a lot
of anti-establishment people what
percentage do you think it's possible
that there could be a trump RFK Jr
president
oh I I don't want to say super high
percentage to be honest with you but
it's funny because people ask me all the
time well who's he considering as a
running mate who anybody on the debate
stage and the truth is he's kept this
one pretty close to the vet I will say
um and so I don't know who he who he's
considering and I don't know if it would
be RFK Jr probably are there
considerations I'm sure there are
absolutely he's considering things
multiple things at all times if if
you're thing about a ticket that says
screw you establishment I think it is a
trump RFK Jr ticket and I think it would
ease a lot of the fears about a new
potential coid virus coming back under
his presidency if RFK Jr was there
saying hey I'm here as vice president I
here will stand up for the people and
for people's uh own um indep individual
rights for their bodies to choose what
they want to do with them I I agree but
I just think there's there's way too
much political baggage
for that to happen a lot a lot of people
have entertained it but I suppose the
the bigger issue is I don't know who
Trump could pick as a running mate we we
we've said a lot of people thought it
would be de santis for a long time and
now that's completely not happening uh V
ramaswami but he says he doesn't want to
be VP but he has to say that but I don't
even know if he would be the right pick
some people are saying Christy Nome I
have no idea it can't be someone close
to his views and his kind of overall
messaging and has to be someone polar
opposite there's a reason he picked Mike
Pence the ne Con well there there's a
reason Biden uh uh was was chosen for
Obama why Obama chose Biden they're
completely different from each other so
if if Trump has a choice right now
between a rhino between a Mike Pence
kind of candidate for his vice
presidency or a a Democrat maybe even a
Tulsi gabard or or an RFK Jr I think
picking a a Democrat will help him out
more than picking a rhino
neoconservative which clearly especially
what happened today a lot of people have
disdain for it yes and I I saw a Twitter
poll from I can't remember who it was
but it was like 10,000 or so votes and I
was surprised to see uh Tulsi gabard got
more votes it's not a scientific poll
I'm just talking about Twitter than uh
uh than VI then RFK Jr people thought
Tulsi gabard would be a good pick I like
Tulsi gabard she's military right yeah
she and she's positioning herself in a
very curious way doing media appearances
speaking tours in a way where she's kind
of but not running I got to be honest
like you know when I think about gnome I
think about RFK Jr V I'm kind of like I
don't know I don't think it's I don't
think telsy gabard has uh uh in my mind
a substantially higher percentage but it
does seem to make more sense he's going
to get a lot of moderate old school and
post- liberal types who are going to be
like with gabard there I I I I I'm I'm
willing to support this yeah there still
is a kind of Bernie bro sentiment within
the Democratic party of of not liking
the establishment there still is the
kind of Jimmy doors out there the
Russell Brands out there that do Glenn
Greenwald that do represent kind of a
leftist kind of anti-establishment
ideology that that could Galvanize a lot
of votes and I think would be more
popular than in yon Joe Rogan said now
twice on his show he would vote for
Trump over Joe Biden Joe Biden is not
there he hasn't gone as far say I'm
going to vote for Trump he's like if it
was Trump Biden I'd vote for Trump over
Biden I think if you had a trump gabard
ticket and again this is we're just
we're just spitting here I mean it's all
just silly nonsense it's probably
meaningless in the big picture but just
thinking about it now I think he's Joe's
friends with Tulsi I think you had a
trump gabard ticket Joe's going to be
like I'm voting for Trump tuls I'm Trump
gabard tuls is my friend I I trust her
yeah you need you need someone that's
going to Galvanize more people outside
of his base that are going to vote for
him as the VP ticket so but I don't even
want to entertain that right because
it's just like it's silly conversation I
mean 6 months from now he's going to
pick someone you're back oh but it could
be that you're just offering ideas that
eventually get around to Dawn and then
that's true no I hope there is someone
here who who knows him I'm just saying
go see gab he like that's a good idea
cuz the baggage about R I like your
impression I I think it was like two
days after he announced he was running
the it's an antivaxx really big on a
news article about him and they hadn't
said that about RFK before that and it
was right when he announced I was like I
got to call my mom get her before the
brainwashing hits because once people
get brainwashed it's harder to
un-brainwash them so when you know it's
coming you tell loved ones right away
and then when they see it they're like
oh he was right and they're ready and
that's what the media is trying to do to
you they're like we got to we've got a
Poison the Well in RFK Jr before people
can talk to their family about it
exactly and there was a coordinated
attack against RFK Jr now he's he's in a
very interesting position because he
also made some very interesting
statements about the border which a lot
of Democrats aren't really making right
now he did flip-flop on the Second
Amendment he has been pretty solid on
his bodily uh autonomy uh that he's been
standing for almost his entire life so
so he's positioning himself in a very
interesting way where he's not far left
and he's not far right but he is
anti-establishment Trump is as well
here's a question I mean we just got a
super chat from Jinger MAAC saying Larry
Elder for VP what do you guys think
about that he did really well in
California Like Larry Elder yeah think
he's a he's a great guy I don't know
enough about him to he's too similar to
Trump that's the problem you have a lot
of alpha energy there on both kind of
yeah it's a hard question I have to
imagine uh uh Trump is strategically you
also want to have someone that if they
impeach you you want to make sure that
they're not going to be more favorable
than you are so you also want a horrible
person like Mike Pence in there or Cala
Harris and and that's why vice president
or or Joe Biden and that's why all the
vice presidents are horrible Dick Cheney
look at all the vice presidents they're
horrible human beings every last one of
them it's perfect yeah yeah it's a
reason that Joe Biden hasn't been
impeached yet as far as I'm concerned
cuz everyone's like oh my God then it's
K Harris Pelosi ticket I'm calling it
right now there you know what I didn't
want to I don't want to spoil it but
that's the ticket there go it's
confirmed we got it oh my gosh now you
are joking but you're going to get some
journalists who say speaking on a on a
on a podcast confirms Pelosi is the
absolutely I'm reached out's office for
comment I think tuls I hope they do tuls
is on the pulse tulsy I like the tulsy
Trump concept because it I started
thinking of like a sun and moon metaphor
when you were talking about that they're
so different you know and but compliment
in a lot of ways I said in like
2019 a similar absurd thing I said if
Trump appointed Tulsi gabard as National
Security adviser and Andrew Yang as an
economic adviser 49 State Landslide and
what I mean by that in that context
specifically was like I mean that
figuratively like it's going to be a
blowout Victory if he does something
like that I
personally for me my my my personal
approval rating on a on a trump gabber
ticket is very high and I'm already
planning on voting for Trump you know
what I mean but I'm like tulsi's tulsi's
military experience means a lot to me
and she's she's moderate you know she
she's called out the Democrats
consistently even going back to 2016 and
I respect that she's got a spine and she
is a balancing force in my opinion she's
younger I think I think that that that
actually works a lot but I I'm I'm you
know I'm still kind of like look I I
don't know man I don't know what the
think she would whip the military into
charge she's awesome she's a well
they're going to need a lot of work
after the past
God bless sad stories man hearing about
people who are retiring because of the
wokeness and
stuff I mean why would we want to focus
on Military Readiness though it's better
to focus on pronouns and things so when
when we're when when we see this this
funding of Ukraine and the verge of
World War II you've had over the past
several months prominent politicians and
political figures in Europe saying we're
in World War III already and not not
talking about Russia I'm talking about
the EU I think the pope even said it at
this time
we need recruitment to be up we need
inspiration we need advocacy but instead
we get the inverse we get these ads that
are super woke that are offensive to
most people who are in the military and
they don't want to join they're retiring
and now we've got this recruitment
shortfall I want to do a genetic
engineering campaign to make super
soldiers so people will be like yo I'm
going to get free genetic crisper
technology and become stronger and
faster I will join that's exactly what
China is doing now and it will get Drive
recruitment no Ian I'm sorry you are
incorrect young kids that want
superpowers that's not how it works they
do the Gen China is doing the genetic
engineering in uh prefertilization it
can be done on adults too but it's
nowhere near the real super soldier
program is China is actually doing this
they're genetically engineering humans
pre- pre-born because when you're
already a human your DNA is already
built a lot of your body they can change
you in certain ways give you hormones
and do crisper stuff but the real
project to make a super soldier is as
you're as you're being fertilized as
they're creating a human they're doing
these weird things genetic yeah yep
there's a book called the hundred-year
marathon it's by Michael Pillsbury and
he documents exactly what the plan in
China is I mean this just kind of feeds
right into it basically they uh have a
hundred years that they expect to take
over as the superpower of the world and
they go about it in a lot of different
ways a lot of it is very covert a lot of
it is playing the victim oh we need help
oh we are not as powerful as the United
States when in fact apparently they're
doing this crazy genetic stuff and doing
making super soldiers already wow let's
be honest America doesn't always have
the best history when it comes to
experimenting on on US soldiers as well
and using them in horrible uh
experiments that usually end end them up
dead or just a shout out to remember
when Joe Biden was referring to the
Tuskegee experiments and called them the
Tuskegee Airmen yes oh man but continue
we we could also do like a techn like
cyber Tech super soldiers where you're
like do you want to get like jumpsuits
and like things that can let you lift
like 1,000 lbs and kids will be like
hell yeah dude yes but if you go to
right now we're seeing that seniors in
high school males are skewing heavily
conservative you go to an 18-year-old
male and say how would you like to have
a superp suit like Iron Man they're like
that'd be really cool all you got to do
is join the military and they're going
to be like that woke garbage yeah
interesting we would need to create a
videos that would propag guys it like um
you propag yeah or I I'll just shorten
to propag guys cuz I'm the man um where
it shows it in badassy all around like
dudes like lifting stuff and throwing
Boulders and stuff and then and then
what's going to happen is
seven-year-olds will be like w but these
these these young young males are going
to be like that's so cool and they're
going to go to their friends and be like
dude you see that military video about
the super suits and they're going to be
like why would you want to join the
military and then they're going to
insert insult about wokeness whatever
whatever joke you want to make and
they're I didn't want to join I was just
saying I saw the commercial that social
pressure is going to be massive the my
my point is simply this sure you may
convince young people with super cool
videos or whatever but a lot of these
young men they are going to be like why
would you do that they're like what are
you a loser prot the country it's not
but it's not it's not after Iraq and
Afghanistan after the botched plot after
Syria I don't think any sane person is
is thinking this not to mention Libya
was a disaster and so you have young
people who are going to go to their
parents Dad I'm thinking about joining
the military why so you can go occupy
some country for 20 years that does
nothing for the American what my dad
said to me after Vietnam he was served
in the Navy in Vietnam he's like if
there's anything in your body that you
want to do anything that you want to do
creatively do not join the military
because it will destroy that part of you
don't do it if you don't want to well
well you look at what they did with
Agent Orange in in Vietnam also very uh
horrendous horrible effects on the US
soldiers there they also had things like
the gay bomb so what you think that
they're doing in China I think it's fair
to say that the American Military
probably has already experimented on and
done here inside of the United States as
of course Echo Health Alliance Dr fouchy
have been playing around with uh
genetics and altering viruses and
sicknesses ever since 2001 after the
Patriot Act was passed by the
Republicans that allowed them to do this
without even being punished or or facing
any repercussions for and now and now I
got this keep it going hold on it's
spill this and he spill it okay Luke
you're making really great points but
instead of talking about Eco Health
Alliance can we point out the men who
stared at Goats do you guys know that
one a little bit when the US government
was experiencing with psychic powers
don't you want to join the military
psychic powers division oh my it's not
covert anymore we know that they're
developing psychic techn like we know
that those things are real so prop
propaganda like make that your military
recruiting there's also MK Ultra there's
also mind control there's also a whole
bunch of stuff and and a lot of really
inhuman psychological and physical
experiments that they've have been doing
on a lot of human beings that are
unsuspecting of a lot of these
experiments that they're participating
in that they have been tested on without
even their knowledge there's an article
here that's pretty interesting by the
South China Morning Post that's
reporting how a team of Chinese
scientists are behind splicing animal
genes into human genes in order to lead
to super soldiers who could survive
nuclear fallout and be resistant to
radiation so this is something that's uh
already happening in China and probably
financed by the United States here
here's the article that L just mentioned
Chinese team behind extreme animal Gene
experiment as it may lead to super
soldiers who survived nuclear fallout
modified human embryonic stem cells
showed Supernatural resistance against
radiation according to a paper by
Academy of military Sciences team in
Beijing Shanghai Bas scientist says
study may open can of worms particularly
when funding is involved and they show a
water bear there for some reason a
grade now the the uh the funny thing I
just you know this is this was okay
Fallout video
games this is a component of the story
that the writers created for that video
game Fallout is is a story where there's
a nuclear war wipes everybody out tons
of people move into vaults and there's
something called the forced evolutionary
virus that attempts to make humans more
resistant to radioactive fallout so they
give people the virus to alter their
genes instead they be they they get
sterilized and their brain capacity
diminishes I don't know about whatever
this is all about but it is funny to me
when you see works of
fiction in some fashion be replicated by
scientists and I think it's because uh
uh people who are writing fiction are
are imagining what the future could be
like with the technology we're
developing and these stories well I'll
give some fictitious future a bunch of
these guys with radiation resistance get
a hold of the nuclear weapons and light
the world up so that they're the ones
that are left now you're talking about
rathan this they actually embedded
tardigrade DNA into human embryonic stem
cells to gain radiation resistance this
is amazing yes is that what it was
tardigrades yeah yes I thought it was
embryonic stem cells they put it into
embryonic stem cells and they it to
solders now you're talking about Wrath
of KH where in Star Trek humans
genetically engineered themselves to
become better and then the genetically
engineered people said we're Superior to
them and so then the humans were like we
got to get rid of these super soldiers
they're really bad sentiment out of
space froze them basically I think I may
be getting the story wrong but that's
generally the idea yeah military.com has
another very interesting article that's
titled the future US military super
soldier may be closer than we think so
these projects again I I was just cating
that they probably are in existence and
uh they are so um what year what is this
what's the date on this one we have it
right here I don't see a date though
military.com is great yeah there's no
date on
this though it may not look like the
process that Steve Rogers went through
it may be coming with the next 30
years that's it and then there's a
famous saying whatever you think uh the
US military has it's usually 30 years
behind for what it already has right now
dudes are going to be able to breathe
underwater like not have to breathe
they'll be able to see super far at
night
but but why do this when we already have
the robot dogs with guns and those
Boston Dynamics robot people cuz robots
can't secure street corners and they can
get shut down by emps robots robots can
uh perhaps I wonder if they can do a
faraday Shield over some of these robots
that Pro probably would I mean I I don't
I they would be pre-programmed AI I
don't know how you control them uh if
their if their signals are are shut down
but yes they can occupy street corners
yeah maybe a street corner but they
can't occupy drones can't but robots can
occupy street corners you guys have a
very bright outlook for what what's
coming first of all you're giving a lot
of credit uh there's a movie that I'm
thinking of Idiocracy has anyone ever
seen that where the half of it doesn't
experiment where this like Average Joe
gets frozen for like a thousand years or
something and when he wakes up Society
has degraded in such a fashion that he
is the smartest person on the planet
Society is in shambles they they don't
know how to farm they're running out of
food they have no water it's a disaster
and their president was uh WWE wrestler
yes exactly and Donald Trump is in the
WWE Hall of Fame so there my and they're
wearing Crocs before Crocs became
popular yes yes yes you look at that
movie and they were wearing Crocs
terrified we're headed down a path more
likely it's not that we're headed we're
here Plastics and the water supply the
the weird pH
but but but but but I I got to hammer
this point that that Democrats sterilize
their kids abort their kids they and
they so while they're actively and and
they and they actively argue against
having kids so while they're doing
everything in their power not to have
children the right is having more kids
and they're fighting a culture War over
children's education so my point here is
if it were true that the left
had unmitigated indoctrination of
children I'd say okay the rights in
trouble your kids are going to get get
indoctrinated but if there's a cultural
battle over what's happening in these
schools and you combine the fact that
Democrats are actively trying not to
have kids give it 20 30 years the
country is back on track I hope so
regarding poisoning of like fat you call
them um forever chemicals p p pfas poor
floral alkal stuff they figured out how
to get them out of out of the soil you
you hit it with lasers you convert the
soil into graphine it removes the P pfcs
the the per alal it out of the graphine
then you put the graphine back into the
soil it fertilizes the soil and you've
removed the forever chemical huh this
graphing is a big deal yeah it's 21st
century steel deal it be the building
material that lightweight build in space
and on Earth we can make clothing out of
it um I'm not wearing any right now I
wear you do you have some graphing
clothing yeah shirts they're they're
really cool in the Heat and and they
keep you warm in the I'm sure they do
it's pure carbon it's just carb if we
could come back to the point I I I I
think a lot of this uh genetic
manipulation is essentially governments
playing with Godlike power and authority
especially when it comes to creating
super soldier babies which obviously has
been happening for a very long time
obviously the Chinese government is
doing it but technology is is really
advancing at such a fast pace that it's
going to outpace our ability to control
it and I think we have already reached a
point where maybe even artificial
intelligence could already be in charge
and we might not even know about it
Terminator exactly but but but it's not
even a Terminator like Society it would
be a lot slower and and a lot more of
human beings acing to it slowly and
surely that would be a lot more
beneficial for the system to kind of
implement their total control on
everyone and and you got to kind of ask
yourself what are they going to be using
radiation resistant super soldiers for
that that's a question that I think we
should be asking ourselves after looking
at to go into the Fallout after the
bombb drops worst case scenario but to
go what you're saying have you guys
noticed this is an
totally that your uh map programs are
malfunctioning in the last couple weeks
if any of you guys had your your like
Google Maps or your ways I've just
noticed twice in the last two weeks from
two different drivers them telling you
to go right and then make a circle and
then go back and then for it's like yo
this could be AI this could be a hack
this could be a CH this is the long War
this is the way the CH this is the way
the first of all you want to confuse
people you're is anyone else reporting
that these things are I'm just wondering
anecdotally if you guys have experienced
it cuz it's happened to me two times
recent and and it clicked like this is
what the Chinese would do to fight along
where you confuse and disorient the
population and if AI is tracking do they
turn right when we tell them to turn
right when they know it's not then then
they'll know like okay so it's easy to
manipulate this one well of course it is
you're right this is but I'm not saying
it's happening now but the strategy
you're you're saying is correct what
they would do is they uh our enemies
whether it be China or Russia or whoever
would not disable GPS they would not
disable Communications GPS would be off
by a degree they would do things like
that then we're less like to notice and
then all of a sudden our cruise missiles
or whatever hypersonics are missing
their targets I asked people on Twitter
today and a lot of them said yeah it was
just anecdote so I remember during
occupy being on the ground covering
these protests you would hear this all
the time even conservatives started
saying it in you know 2017 2018 when
they started going out more and being in
large crowds that oh the feds are
jamming our cell phones they're shutting
our phones down so we can't communicate
and I'm like no dude you you don't
understand they're spying on you they
want your phones to work in fact
they deploy mobile cell units to high
protest to high traffic areas and
protests to make sure your phones don't
go down cuz they're spying on your phone
went down because there's too many
people here and the cell towers can't
handle it people don't understand they
think our enemies would disable GPS no
that's ridiculous they would spy on our
GPS to track everything we do they want
us using these things yeah yeah data is
the new oil and data harvesting and
getting information on people also
getting their DNA
is something that the Chinese government
has been doing uh in a very aggressive
way the FBI couple years ago sent out a
memo during coid saying hey if you're
taking a coid test uh just make sure
you're you're disposing of the swab
since there's been Chinese government
and Chinese government connected
corporations taking those swabs and then
data harvesting DNA from the American
people in order to of course not just
game the big Pharma system but more
importantly also just get the genetic
information of their American people
which could potentially be used for
genetic bioweapons as we know are also
in progress and in the works by the US
Pentagon just because I already know
those people were going to say Luke's a
conspiracy theorist here's the article
from NPR China wants your data and may
already have it well what data are you
referring to your DNA that's right as
CO's cases begin to rise a year ago
Chinese company contacted several US
states and offered to set up testing
Labs as a byproduct the Chinese firm
Beijing genomics Institute would likely
gain access to the DNA of those tested
you know when I tell people that China's
stealing your DNA they go okay you're
insane so I don't say it that way I say
do you see that NPR article something
about a Chinese company taking coid
tests to get the DNA out of it and that
still sounds insane but don't worry I
just show them the article and say I
don't know man NPR's reporting it I have
a different approach I say China is
stealing your DNA the US government
already has it and is weaponizing it and
probably using it against you as we
speak right now so should I not have
done the 23 in me no that information
also is being found to be sold on the
black market everything you if if
something is free you are the product so
every little piece of information their
data mining the NSA the the US
government is collecting them in major
servers and it's it's not just uh you
know your DNA it's also the keystrokes
it's also your heart rate it's also your
biometric data that's being collected
without your permission uh what are you
pointing at Point at your wrists both of
yourist there's a specific but there's a
specific strategy that you implement
where you don't give your information
off and someone like uh you know you're
someone like a ligma uh Johnson right
instead of Luc rowski this company now
just hold on hold on let me pause right
there they don't care about lukowski's
vitals they care about the anonymized
data when they say things like we don't
we don't take your information or they
say like we're going to collect your
information for Diagnostic reasons but
we do not attach your identity to it it
will be randomized and no one will know
who you are what they do when they take
your DNA assuming they do they don't
care your name they're mapping
populations they mapping
characteristics and because so many
people have taken it upon themselves
even me I'm wearing a a Garmin watch
which tracks Health they all do it now I
I actually I like the benefits I get
from it but I recognize all of us are
snowflakes in an avalanche when they
collect all this data they can
collectively see detrimental Health uh
uh circumstances they can also formulate
bioweapons using that data and they can
say when and the AI knows all of this
people need understand the depth of AI
calculations they're going to say we
tracked all of the of the whoops and all
the Gins and all the smart watches in
Florida when the when the smog from
Canada came in and we saw a collective
7% decrease in blood oxygenation and a
23% increase in heart rate they are
going to actually be able to map this
stuff they're going to see it was record
temp the temperature was 80° they're
going to be able to look at every every
place on the planet that where was
recorded 80° what were the heart rates
of the average person that kind of data
can be weaponized in very terrifying
ways especially with the Apple watches
especially with tomorrow's 5G emergency
test that's happening at 2:30 p.m.
eastern time uh someone in the comment
section also said something pretty funny
uh someone said 23 and CCP and uh that's
pry that's over for me I know did the
bioweapons are coming they're made just
for you what's your ancestry I gotta
know might well get something out of it
oh what what's your guess what do you
think um Swedish I am part Scandinavian
yes I was going to say I yeah Swedish
but Scandinavian that could be Norwegian
Danish well I they didn't get specific
it was it was right it shows the region
yeah the region uh Eastern European
Scandinavian and uh apparently England
Scotland through your DNA data you could
also find out what kind of diseases and
sicknesses you're more prevalent to get
and what kind of drugs work uh for you
and don't work for you uh based off your
genetics as well we were talking about
some of that very stuff with some of the
friends that we know that also work in
the health industry that are trying to
revolutionize it but you know there's
things that are that are just double
edge swords these things are two-way
mirrors man it's like the value of what
you can learn through devices and Tech
like this but then they're also learning
it they being whoever but you know
organizations are also learning your
data well and we're so reliant on it
it's I mean honestly I think about when
I was a kid and we didn't have all of
this stuff when you used a map and you
had to go somewhere and pick up a phone
instead of having it in your pocket it
was just
we are we are so so reliant on these and
if your phone dies for like an hour
you're like in a panic it is it's
terrifying to think of remember not
knowing yes kids kids today don't they
don't yeah that's crazy they never
will you ask your friend like you know
who is that rapper who sang uh Gangsters
Paradise like don't know do you know how
long it took me to figure out songs when
I would like recite them for people and
be like do now we have tape them off the
radio waiting to now you can you can
pull up the app and you can sing to it
and it will tell you the song of course
even if the lyrics are wrong I would
wait weeks or you just hold your cell
phone up and find out exactly what song
it is no but I'm saying if you get a
song stuck in your head and you're like
what is that song you can just
go and then it'll pop up and tell you
what it is so people are correcting me
in the chat it's not 2:30 p.m. it's 2:20
p.m. and there's a very interesting
article from The Verge that's talking
about how 23 and me already sold your
rights to a drug development company
that's working on a genetic database in
order to of course provide you uh drugs
in the future that you don't take a lot
of drugs so big Pharma drugs what's this
test that you're talking about this 5G
test tomorrow so they're doing a an
Emergency Alert uh test with FEMA with
uh all cell phones and communication
devices using uh I believe 5G and then
this has spurred a lot of people to
bring out different theories of what's
really happening here I think it's it's
you know a test but uh I don't want to
be a part of it I don't want to
participate in in this kind of test I
will and all the other devices in both
of your watches all of them you can't
take your your battery out anymore yep
you can't you used to so I during Occupy
Wall Street after the big protests and
you know I got featured in in magazine
stuff I could not turn my phones off so
I had an iPhone and an Android I used
the Android as as my actual phone and
the iPhone was had a better camera and
streamed higher quality iPhone's battery
could not be removed Android could both
phones could not be turned off if I
turned them off they would instantly
turn back on so I took the battery out
of the Android but the iPhone wow would
instantly turned back on no matter what
I did I held on the uh the Android 5 for
so long cuz you could still take the
battery out I just waited till the 9:
and I couldn't take anywhere so slow it
became obsolete I'm reliant on the thing
you're talking about Reliance on this
Tech I don't know if this is real but
this guy his name is Martin Peltier he's
a Canadian dude M Peltier uh CIO on
Twitter he's got his he's got these
pictures of screenshots of his Instagram
and it says people in Canada can't see
this content in response to Canadian
government legislation news content
can't be viewed in Canada I can't tell
if it's real it's Breitbart CNN that's
real so they people are becoming riing
on this Tech and then a government goes
and like Cuts your artery to it and like
how do you how do you survive if they do
that to you the UK is
next I this is just Instagram but like
if it's your bank if it's your direction
apps like there was that article saying
they want to ban Rumble in the UK over
Russell Brand your phone if you just all
of a sudden don't have techn like don't
have communication technology like
that's it's a human rights violation
there's there's already stores where you
walk in and they say credit only card
only no cash and you know we're talking
about neuralink and the metaverse and
stuff like that and because every all
these conser like I'll never do it I
won't do it and I'm like yeah you will I
mean no no maybe you won't but I'm
saying Society will why cuz you're going
to walk in a Taco Bell and you're going
to go up to the kiosk there's no human
beings and you're going to be like you
know cheesy Gita crunch cheesy git
crunch cheesy git crunch extra extra
sauce and pay
and then it's going to say neural pay
and you're going to be like uh where do
I put my card where do I tap my card and
it's going to be like we no longer
accept cards neural pay only and you're
going to back it'll be like Focus third
eye here and it'll show like the red
glow and you'll be like what what
they're implementing they already tested
and uh are using currently in China
right now especially with their social
credit score where people have their
face scanned and if they have the wrong
political thoughts and ideas they can't
buy groceries they can't travel on
high-speed train they can't get get
high-speed internet they can't of course
get their kids into the proper schools
and that of course keeps a society in
line and obeying governments and not
questioning them as of course many
journalists many activists have been hit
with a poor social credit score and in
America we already have a very similar
system that's not really talked about
it's a corporate social credits score as
of course a lot of your data is being
harvested a lot of your data is being
sold and your thoughts and expressions
are also being judged very heavily uh
and you just don't know about it yet and
it has been fully implemented but the
databases the systems in order to fully
roll this out are there and I think
they're just going to slowly and surely
get us used to these ideas and then
implement it all for our safety and our
well-being and in reality it's it's
something that is Draconian technocratic
and meant to destroy human
civilization jeez yeah I'm tired of the
I'm doing this for your own good like
that's obviously that's when someone
says that to you in a movie or that you
know that the character's lying if they
say say that to someone in a movie so
like that that people are trying to do
this like you want to cut down my my
access to carbon for for my own good
have you guys seen the new Disney movie
which I it was like wish or something I
for it's called where it's the king no
has magic powers and can grant wishes
but he only grants certain wishes that
he thinks will will help the country and
then this young girl discovers like the
ability like she gets the ability to
grant wishes and then she's like we've
got to Grant everyone's wish and the
King's like someone's coming for my
power and it's just like
quite it it's so obviously an attack on
capitalist meritocracy you can't just
grant everyone's wishes but the
Communists are like yes we can yeah
really can they play on your desire to
free the slaves that's what that sounds
like as a movie about freeing the slaves
give everyone the road to predition but
like is that the right word predition
but in reality giving everyone ultimate
control is not like we're not we're
we're slaves to reality we can't if we
all had Fusion packs one of those
monkeys is going to drop it on the
ground and blow everything up so we got
to be maybe not Fusion Vision packs if
we all fishion packs so we got to you
got to limit people I I this is a long
conversation all right we're going to go
to super chats if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it head over to
timcast.net first Tim will Elite and VIP
members have preferred seating at the
live show in Miami I am working on that
ideally yes uh that's I I think for
elite members
especially yes but again I'm not
organizing the event our company is and
there's like people who are in charge of
it and there's a lot of like paperwork
and stuff so let me let me sort that out
and we'll get back to uh guys on the
Discord all right fix bayonets says
Gates should nominate Mark
Levin okay all right well Donald Trump's
in the running Raymond gy JR says Tim
marjerie Taylor Green's words were Hold
the Line BS let's just stand here so
they can beat us back Gates on the other
hand is forwarding the line he made the
aggressive bet to see if they got the
balls and he won seriously really I I
think he's doing a great job man let's
uh let's see what we got let's see what
we got big 7588 says police already
abused the 5150 hold do not use it for
drug addiction well what's the
alternative
right what what are we supposed to do
about the violent drug addicts in San
Francisco and in you know I'll throw
California that we're seeing in New York
if someone is mentally unstable what do
we do just lock them up that's a tough
question I don't I mean I don't have a
great answer but we have to do something
you can't just I mean look at what look
at the result right now take a look
around does it seem like things are
great they we used to have mental
institutions yeah now we just have
people open air drug markets drug abuse
Philly has that I forgot what they're
calling it where it's like you see this
open air drug Market of people zombieing
around you've got Skid Row you've got
San Francisco now it's it's
everywhere I don't I I think you have to
get people off the streets if they're on
drugs and incapable of taking care of
themselves I don't know what the answer
is probably but that was the argument I
was making earlier that's why he's
saying no to 5150s I I assume that they
tried the jail thing before and it it
was just too inhumane so they they were
like we need better condition jails
institutions and then they were like
well that's not even Humane but then I
viv's big on this he's saying we need to
reopen institutions and but we need to
make them actually good and and clean
and like give them access to technology
like webcam so they can talk to their
families and stuff while they're there
all right here's one for Lara T-Rex Bop
asks why did Donald Trump defend
McCarthy and the establishment that's
one thing we criticize him for why
doesn't he listen to us also he's asking
do you have pets we are an anti-woke
alternative to woke chewy petmart and
Petco from T-Rex pet oh I love that I
have three dogs uh I have a Beagle a
hound mix and a miniature Yorkie um so
yeah we'll check that out thank you why
did he defend McCarthy well I think if
you look back McCarthy has been actually
an ally of my father-in-law's while he
was in the white house I don't know
today what he has said about it it
sounds like he actually said that he
thought what happen was rather positive
and gave kudos to Matt Gates so I don't
know I would have to check with him on
exactly where he stands on that right
now yeah I think uh he said something
I'm not sure I didn't see the video but
someone said that recently Trump said
I've got nothing bad to say about him
he's always been nice to me or something
to that effect and it's like oh whatever
yeah it's always got to divide
criticizing the man himself and he seems
like a pretty cool guy with his his
actions in the role he also truthed
today that the rep Republicans shouldn't
be fighting each other but they should
be fighting the radical left well we got
this one from load 200 saying Matt Gates
doesn't have the balls to run for
Speaker of the House Matt Gates just
gave the Democrat gave democratic party
a win thanks for uh thanks no for
nothing Gates I think meant thanks for
nothing Gates oh I think Gates did the
the right thing but I there are a lot of
people that share that sentiment that
was the no votes so Kevin McCarthy is
doing deals with Democrats in defiance
of what the Republican Party actually
was negotiating on then you you don't
have the Republicans don't have a
majority you democrat he had to do the
machine he he had to become the machine
for a moment I don't think he's like
happy in any way about this did Matt no
Gates Matt Gates you mean he's doing
he's doing what needs to be done
mechanically for the situation he knows
that it's like speaker does not comply
speaker must go and everyone else is
like hey it's not a video game it's not
a math problem there's more to it and
he's like speaker did not comply speaker
must go and it's like in some waying
hard decisions yeah yep and and there's
value to that there's value to people
that are able to do that to set aside
their desires and to make the those hard
decisions rivian Creek says tulsy for
speaker she's an independent
now yeah maybe I think considering
nobody wants it a democrat's not going
to get it Republicans might have to find
an outside speaker like I know the
Donald Trump thing is funny but they
he's running for president so I don't
think he would do it they might need to
find someone former member of Congress
who would who not a bad idea um I like
Dr No Better uh Ron Paul I think he
would be the perfect candidate for the
bring R back he always voted no on
everything all right BR Zack says Tim
I'm a vet and would lose $2,000 a month
it would be tough but worth it let's go
Matt Gates wow that's right on man I
hear I know not everybody uh in your in
a similar position could agree with that
you know people who need those benefits
that's why it's tough yeah like what
percentage of your net income or net
wealth is 2,000 because sometimes if
it's only a drop in the bucket for you
it's understandable if it's 95% of your
income then that could be a different
story but I I'm with you
man all right we'll grab some more Super
chats what do we got saddle effing
says McCarthy is facing the consequences
of his actions as Speaker he thought
once he was in business as usual Matt
Gates held him accountable for once I
appreciate it man and then Mr Busco says
I nominate Ron Paul as sacrifice there
you go as tribute that's true yeah what
do we got Violet gray says stop saying
vet pay is affected it isn't I am not
talking literally about right now I'm
saying one of the things Matt Gates
brought up was that this is I mean and
and Kevin McCarthy said this as well
payment for the troops and veterans
benefits so Matt said one of the first
things they did when it was all going
down was making sure they had a single
subject spending bill for veteran
benefits Terence Max says VI ramaswami
for house
Speaker every everybody who's in
politics right now especially those
running for president are not going to
take a position like this no do you need
to be
nonpartisan like is that the are they
supposed to be nonpartisan who who are
people suggesting like Justin aash or
something and I'm like he'll get removed
in two seconds again I don't think you
need to be nonpartisan I think they've
all been I mean it's you know no I don't
think think Nancy Pelosi's nonpartisan
no they I they haven't been nonpartisan
I'm wondering if they if we got one if
that would if they like literally didn't
take sides they just kind of spoke the
will of the Congress isn't that
impossible these days yeah it's
definitely
idealistic sah thinks a lot says Ukraine
has every right to self-defense we have
every interest in stopping hostile
foreign powers we aren't sending Ukraine
cash we're sending equipment equipment
that we could use in our own country and
we could be using our resources whatever
they may be equipment or otherwise to I
don't know secure our Southern border
and worry about what Americans are
woring about how about this Ukraine
certainly has a right to self-defense
good luck Ukraine I wish you the best
how about we take those resources and I
don't know like fix our roads our
bridges how right right now in West
Virginia they shut down 34 340 for rock
slide abatement and it's causing a major
crisis I for like the locals it's not
like a national crisis but now the the
roads around this highway are being torn
up and destroyed why don't we invest
back in our infrastructure which is in
serious trouble yeah bit human you can
and good luck to Ukraine man I wish you
the best I it's I it's it's unfortunate
you know I I don't see what the argument
is here there are a lot this is a little
tangential a lot of good Technologies to
make better roads but I think the
planned obsolescence is profitable for
the the machine that builds them so they
just keep using asphalt I can't tell but
you could like put graphine I mean all
right it's getting hot
wow Scott bra on ear says but Tim still
won't speak about defending Israel they
get $880 billion a year let's have a
real chat Tim I am particularly annoyed
by the people who are obsessed with
Israel for some reason which is one of
the issues but uh we'll talk about that
all the time we've done full segments
talking about the various spending that
the US has given overseas and we've
talked about wasteful spending in the
Middle East and V ramaswami was roasted
for talking about how he wanted to get
Israel to the point where they could
defend themselves what's the point my
issue often with people who talk about
Israel is like they do these non seers
to force you to talk about Israel and
it's so annoying they'll like I'll keep
it vague but in the past there'd be
people like in a chat room and they'd
say something like hey did you guys try
this new pizza restaurant that opened in
Brooklyn and this is actually I'm
talking about I'm being I'm being vague
but this is directly related to uh to
the work that I'm doing and then someone
would be like yeah it was really good
you know i' I've had pizza all over the
world really where're at Israel you know
the thing about Israel is and then I'm
just like you know what dude there are
people who are so desperate and obsessed
with just Israel and I'm like I get it
man but the bigger issue I'm talking
about is all foreign policy and all
foreign spending I'm not focused on one
country we're talking about Ukraine
because Ukraine is the thing they're
voting on and funding right now but yes
I agree I think we should reassess a lot
of a lot of this that being said when
Donald Trump was in office we had the
Abraham Accords historic peace
agreements you actually had Commerce
from the was it Saudi Arabia the
Emirates into Israel amazing wow I know
thanks Donald Trump yeah seriously so
why don't we that seems like a solution
to the problems if no one's fighting
then maybe we don't need to waste money
anymore and then all these leftists were
like yeah Trump just bribed them I'm
like well look at this offer money and
say the economic incentives for you to
stop fighting are tremendous if you guys
are not in Conflict you're going to be
super rich and then fighting stops I'll
take it no new Wars under Donald Trump
I'll say that for me just stop all
foreign fund and like why are we giving
other people money uh we have a lot of
problems at home give it back to the
American people to ensure that they
spend it so they keep using the petet
dollar that's why they gave the gender
studies money in Pakistan at least
that's one reason it's a big reason they
they give our money out so that people
are like I got money I can use it and
then they spend it it's to build
confidence in the Petro dollar to F to
to challenge bricks and all that stuff
like what a stupid idea dilute the
savings of the American people and the
argument is yeah but then our our our
economy which produces nothing is
propped up based on the fact that other
people use our money and it's just like
how about we bring manufacturing back
and we do some work secure our borders
bring back jobs I'm sure people would
rather in West Virginia make cars
instead of sitting around gambling and
and doing opioids dude we're going to
build a space elevator on the moon
you're saying out of graphite yeah
graphine graphine Sor graphine is when
it becomes a hexagonal lattice it looks
like a honeycomb yeah it's awesome I'll
show you a picture of it later or maybe
we can pull one up I don't think Tim
will Mega glaive says politicians who
vote for bills they don't have time to
read should be impeached for violating
their oath to office they have a duty to
verify that the bill is constitutional
and they cannot do this if they don't
know what is in it what what is in it I
completely
agree but that's not the world that we
live in right now Matt Gates was talking
about that today saying we need to read
the bills we need to understand what
we're passing they don't they just
literally put their stamp on approval
well we had when margorie Taylor green
was on the show she talks about how
there's like eight Republicans and eight
Democrats and some guy she doesn't she
she comes into Congress and she sees
like eight Democrats eight Republicans
and some guy in the speaker's position
she doesn't know who it is and he's just
like here's a bill yeah okay it's passed
here's another bill no then it's not
let's have it for the Y and they're like
Nays and then they just do it by sound
and they go sure
it's a voting system no no no no no no
no no no marjerie said the majority of
bills it is only eight of each from the
party no one's there they're all on
fundraising phone calls and someone who
is not the speaker is reading off the
bills and they just go whatever and then
what she started doing with the freedom
caucus was as soon as they would go
here's a bill nah floor vote and they'd
have to call every member of Congress
back in to actually vote on it yeah and
she was describing how everyone was
really mad at her cuz they had to
actually go on the house floor and why
that's why they removed their committee
positions and assignments because
they're like we don't want to do work
wow yep nice I'd like to see a felony
that they should under oath testify that
they read the bills before you even have
a right to vote on it and then a felony
if they violate that so how do we change
it though you know like what's the
what's the plan you could do a
Convention of States but that can get
that can become dangerous cuz other
people people could do it um and change
the Constitution without congress's
Authority otherwise we could try and get
them to do it to themselves a Convention
of states will still require voting on
proposed amendments and the risk is the
states may agree to amend the
Constitution but you don't know how the
states will actually vote to amend the
Constitution could because that's that's
where things get more specific there's
fears that they could take away the
right to keep in bar arms or something
like that I'm not concerned about that
if Republican states have the majority
and call the convention of states which
they're relatively close and might
happen I'm confident that the Amendments
would probably be okay they can add to
the Second Amendment or how about what
are we on 27 was be the 28th I don't
know we can add amendment being like
just to reiterate when we said you have
a right to keep in bar arms we mean all
at any point any accessory any amount of
ammunition the founding fathers had
private warships so uh we're good they
can do something like that or I mean
honestly how would yall feel if they
amended the Constitution to say the
right keeping be arms is universal
except in the instance of you uh
biological and nuclear
weapons that's that's fair let's not
have those I want my nuclear weapons
that's an interesting question because
uh private companies are the ones that
make them exactly and so when you know
I've had this argument about people have
a a right I said people have a right to
keep in Bear biological and nuclear
weapons and I got all these Progressive
screaming like Tim's nuts he's insane
and I'm like who do you think makes them
do you think that like a government
agency makes these weapons they don't it
is the military industrial complex like
you know locked Martin and and rathon
these companies are making nuclear
weapons for the government which means
they're privately owned that's always
how it's been yep and selling the
technology to other countries as well
yeah you got to love it don't you
H dick Dickerson says malice for speaker
yes obviously but come on I don't think
he would take it no one's going to
nominate him although that would be
absolutely fantastic I think the longer
we go without a speaker the more chance
of a radical
populist to get put in from outside the
system like Oprah or I whoever but
someone famous that'll just be like Brad
Pit he walks in and everyone's
like I just if it gets to a point where
people are become desperate to get a
house speakers the life of D says gag
orders are anti-ir Amendment people are
allowed to say whatever they want don't
like it change the Constitution that is
interesting uh I've been involved in
lawsuits before I assume you probably
have most people to a certain degree
depending on the business you're in but
gag orders are fairly common and I'm not
I'm not super opposed to it the
challenge I find is that
when depending on the court you're in
you may end up with a judge being like
okay both parties there's a gag order
you can't disparage each other one party
will do it the judge will do nothing
about it so often what we see is hey
don't you do this thing your opposition
does it and then you're like hey they're
doing it they're like yes that's it's
whatever who cares and I'm like so
should I do it no don't you dare and I'm
like so Break The Rules or what that's
the problem I have with it the judge has
cameras in the court cour room the judge
is like I'm going to do whatever I want
he's going to laugh and smile for the
camera and say Trump better not talk
about it he better not criticize my
staff for their political biases
somebody uh it's it might have been Mark
Twain quote said that it's better to
just break just to do the I don't want
to get this quot but it's better to like
apologize for breaking the rule than to
ask if you can break the rule better
it's better to apologize ask for
forgiveness than permission yes yeah I I
despise that me too I don't like that
that just that sociological what that
could create I don't like that no I I
definitely do not agree with that uh I
understand the advantages to doing
something and then being like whoopsy
Daisy after the fact but uh when you're
running a company and you have a lot of
people who have that ethos of I'll just
do it and ask for forgiveness later I'm
like that doesn't work very well nope no
hey there's like a reason why we said
not to do this thing you went and did it
and now the house is on fire it's like
so uh yeah well then you could not
forgive them you could choose not to
forgive them you know I mean I think
part of the problem these days every
everybody so these kids honestly the the
upcoming Generations I'm really
terrified about they're so soft there's
no punishment that I mean the the way
that kids are raised today is so so
different than the way I was raised I
mean it is I'm really wondering if
anyone will have any work ethic at all
they'll have any sort of direction as to
what they want to do in life everybody's
just like a free-for-all of just
coddling and it's it's honestly scary so
I agree maybe maybe you ask for
forgiveness and you don't get it so yeah
I think the the issue is there are some
circumstances where you don't need to
ask for permission and there are some
circumstances where you do and if too
many people have this idea that I'm not
going to ask for permission to do a
thing that negatively that could
potentially negatively impact people
it's like well now you're creating
serious risks for others but if it's an
issue of like a benign victimless thing
of I don't know if this road is open or
not I'm just going to go down it we'll
see what happens like okay well the guy
don't do it again yeah but if it's like
I'm just going to drink the milk I don't
know whose it is don't do that I I grew
up with the brother that did that it's
so annoying this this ethos is like you
open the fridge at work and you you see
a delicious ham sandwich that says like
you know JF on you're like don't know
what that means but I'll just ask JF for
forgiveness after I eat his lunch and
it's and then the guy walks in and it's
John fedman and he's like yo you ate my
uh what and then you're like well he
can't even articulate his anger anyway
so now I don't go to apologize what you
think about um Mass pardons as a
political tactic oh well in I mean for
all everyone Hillary Joe Hunter Donald
everyone in prison for j6 uh we could
even go deep deep uh deep something that
would benefit both sides or all sides
well I mean I think that my
father-in-law has said that he probably
would do take care of the January 6th
folks I mean he's going to do something
to rectify the abuses that these people
have suffered it's really insane but
Ian's talking about pardoning Hunter
Biden well I mean that's a tactic to
consider for sure CU then you just level
it all and you just say enough with this
can we just focus on actually what
people care about which is getting this
country back in order I can I can
understand the point Ian's making I'm
I'm not for it but I can understand the
idea being you go to them and say stop
fighting us we are taking over Trump
will be president we're not going to
imprison you and now the conflict is
done and the idea is right now they're
leveling everything they have at Trump
and Trump supporters in panic and
Desperation and if Trump went and said
you guys leave right now no more no more
no more attacks on us and when I'm
President we won't lock you up for the
rest of your lives you'll get to be rich
and be comfortable but we're done we're
in charge now they might actually back
down I don't think they will is the
issue the problem too is you know when
you look at what is is pretty obviously
going on with the bidens it's really a
national security issue at a certain
point I mean how do you know that the
decisions Joe Biden is making in the
white house and we know that that is I
mean we're being very kind by saying
he's making decisions in the white house
he can barely string a sentence together
are based on what he thinks is best for
the country and not what's best for the
Biden Pockets you know what I mean and
so I think if what is being implied has
happened with Joe and Hunter Biden I
mean really selling this country out
that is a really awful place to find
ourselves in the United States and man
we never want to go back there so we
better take care of that problem and I
don't know if you want to just let that
one sail off into the sunset unchecked
that doesn't feel right to me right I I
think we are a nation of laws and for
too long there's been no accountability
and what they're doing the more they do
it just me like show is like we need to
weed out the corruption through a legal
process there needs to be legitimate
investigations indictments and I would
love it but it's like we investigated
ourselves we found we did nothing wrong
that's not that's not it Donald Trump
getting in office is not investigating
ourselves it's him saying look at what
you were doing when you were in power
and investigating look look at the steel
dossier I was going to say what about
the FBI what about the CIA what about
the doj itself like if we just kind of
say we're going to just call it even
here we got to get to the heart of this
I mean this stuff is so corrupt it is so
rotten at the core to know that the CIA
and the FBI have now meddled in two
presidential elections we know that we
can't just kind of turn and be like
let's call it even I I feel like I know
so so my answer is no I I think of it as
like um a hostage negotiation kind of at
this point because I'm tired of seeing
everybody yeah it's just so exhausting
and it is as five trillion has been
printed and it's still really it's still
Joe Biden versus Donald Trump I'm
getting tired of that you guys like we
got to solve this if we're going to
survive we got rabbert G stanberg Junior
saying I swear one day graphine will be
a common material used all around the
world and Ian will be the old man
screaming you all called me crazy waving
his fist the young people on their
graphine hoverboards Ian how much did
you pay him to write that I wrote that
my Super Chat no I'm just kidding um
what'll happen is I'll tell everyone I
Told You So once but then you got to be
humble and not be like I'm the one that
told everyone guys listen Ian's going to
have a gigantic 10 story tall Vault
where he will climb to the top and it'll
be full of gold coins and he will dive
into it and swim around because he's
invested in graphine stock I want to be
free for people I'll be honest when Ian
started screaming about graphine I
bought stock in a company that
manufactures graphine graphine products
and it's one of the only stocks that I
have that's continually performed
positively it's 2029 investigate this
when I leave here I'm like I don't know
anything about it all I know is I
Googled company that makes graphine and
it's like here's the company and then
I'm like I'm up everything else is bad
we I was in Chile in 2018 working on
starting a graphine company with this
chin this Chilean billionaire and all he
wanted was how much money you going to
make I'm like that's not why I'm doing
this dude and then in our research we
saw in 2029 you're going to start to see
Peak graphine um inflection which is
where Society now starts to use it like
normal so we still got a few more years
to start investing and I'm not giving
investment advice you've been in on this
for a while I see yeah yeah all right
Brian B says I can't believe I agree
with Ian we currently have reps
representing all three rural suburbs and
city in their District a republic can't
protect the minority when rep survival
depends on ignoring the minority for the
majority yeah well I don't know if more
members of congress makes it easier
probably makes it more difficult yeah
but I don't know what you do I mean it's
honestly it makes it slower I don't know
if that's worse we got a big super chat
from Seth weathers he says the world may
be on fire but you can still get
conservative dad's Revenge the Trump
mugshot limited edition beer can see in
Miami shout out to Seth weathers uh did
you hear about that he sold what what is
he about to hit like $2 million he
launched a beer company called Ultra uh
conservative dads Ultra right beer
because of Bud Light wow and then they
launched a limited edition Trump mug
shot can and he sold like half a million
dollars in half a day wow yeah love that
yep that's the beauty of America right
there yeah we we made a we made a
graphic of Trump's mug shot but like the
Obama hope poster and then we just told
everybody they could have it it's like
we just made the art we put it it's free
it's not ours we don't own it it's just
the mug shot and then people are making
mugs or making stickers and posters and
it'll be really great you know I
remember when I was younger when Obama
was running they had all those hope
posters everywhere it would so amazing
to see in 2024 Revenge everywhere just
Trump's mug shot in that art
Revenge it's a lot of Americans feel
man thinker for Life says Uh Oh YouTube
just jumped on us they always do that
all right here we go inserting Trump as
Speaker equals a triple benefit we'll
get a jump on cleaning out the Deep
State the Dems in congress with Trump
derangement syndrome will short circuit
and clear themselves out the Witch Hunt
is diverting his time anyway be on
Center Stage as Speaker while running I
guess I don't I think it'd be hilarious
if he took it it might be worth just
seeing the reaction I I would kind of
just to get you know what I mean could
you imagine like of all people I just
remember like Rachel mattow after my
father-in-law had won and he was
officially president-elect and she the
the next time she was on TV she was like
this is not a nightmare you are waking
up this is not a nightmare imagine if he
became Speaker of the House kind it
would kind of be worth it do you
remember when Muller came out and said
that the conclusion was Donald Trump did
not colluded with Russia and she was on
the verge of crying yes these people are
nuts I'm sitting there I'm like oh wow
look at that Trump was was innocent hey
you know the country moves forward and
they're like on the verge of tears like
no he needs they wanted it to be true MH
that's insane man and then they dug so
deep they found themselves yeah there
are a lot of people who have uh uh
attached themselves to a political
movement and then when that movement
starts faltering they're panicked like
I've dedicated too much to this I can't
turn around now yeah but it should be
like the scientific method where you
want your experiment to fail you you
want to poke every possible hole in the
thing until it fails and then you you
scrap it and start a new process same
with your political party that's what it
should be Arthur Charles says Lara were
you prepared to be on nerdcast IRL was
it because we were talking about Star
Trek and stuff oh I don't know I've
never really watched Star Trek I watched
Star Wars what' you think I loved Star
Wars I haven't watched all the new ones
there's too many I watched the first
three The Originals that's all I know
yeah but maybe I wasn't prepared next
time I'll watch a lot of Star Trek you
guys talk a lot of sci-fi in the house
not a lot not necessarily did you get
that did you think I was no actually I
thought you weren't but I wanted to ask
because I didn't want to assume no not a
lot of
sci-fi all right Char deetz says today
was the first bravery from Republicans
we've seen in years everyone may not
like it but we need accountability I
guess it was eight Republicans I said it
11 earlier I was wrong I think it's
eight and uh it's Democrat opportunists
and eight Republicans willing to stand
up and say no to the establishment in
all fairness there might be a lot of
Democrats that also are tired of the
establishment that voted to get him out
because yeah but I don't think so like
ilhan she didn't matter her pretty tight
I don't know there was that photo
everyone's sharing did you see it where
she's like licking her lips and looking
at met Gates and everyone's like
catching this excuse me I don't think
she's actually looking at Matt Gates she
was probably just sitting there and
someone caught an awkward photo all
right everybody if you hav he's not her
brother okay okay if you haven't
already please would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you do like it and head over to
timcast.net
Instagram and truth thank you this was
fun thank you so much for coming on if
you want to to support me check out take
the chill pill.com it's my own line of
supplements that I use under high stress
it helps me it might help you do your
own homework do your own research take
to chill pill.com and uh Ian Freeman of
free talk live was by the way sentenced
to eight years in jail yesterday I think
that's uh pretty crazy for what uh
essentially uh selling Bitcoin without a
license um I'm I'm I'm just generalizing
the case here find out more about it and
learn about this case on free.com
and uh yeah I think it's outrageous that
he was sentenced to 8 years you have a
podcast or a show I do yes the Right
View it's the right view.com you've
heard of the view this is about 180
degre in the opposite direction uh so we
hope people get smarter watching it not
dumber when is it uh it's three days a
week Tuesdays Wednesdays and Thursdays
what time uh 8:00 P.M Eastern yes right
gosh look at you all over on it and when
people follow you on Twitter X it's Lara
Lee it's l a r a l e a which you found
out the hard yes I had to ask I'm still
humiliated thanks for coming La great to
meet you man and thanks for letting me
be weird you guys I promise you in 15
years graphine will be normalized I'm
not going to be talking about as much
and your machines will be a lot more
lightweight Ian really came from a time
traveling machine so he knows what when
I look into the sky I see the future
bounce back at me so let's keep it going
Splurge uh yeah I'm just hanging out
here I'm ready for the after show when
you guys are all right everybody we will
see you all over at timcast.net